hello everybody welcome to the october
2021 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll and greetings from sunny boston
massachusetts where i remain for my
visit here to the harvard philosophy
department it is sunny actually at this
exact moment but it as cliche as it is
what i have to comment on is the weather
here in the northeastern united states
because you know i live in los angeles
and have for the past 15 years or so
where it's sunny and dry
almost all the time in the right
temperature
and actually i've been blessed with the
right temperature pretty much here in
the northeast but boy is it humid and i
say this as someone who lived in boston
for eight years and before that uh in
pennsylvania for many years but i i kind
of forget that 75 degrees in the
northeast is just not the same weather
as 75 degrees in los angeles
that's about it for my uh deep insights
here because i've mostly for the past
month been just concentrate
concentrating on getting books written
and other things that i've had to do you
know revising papers and writing letters
of recommendation it's that part of the
year
uh doing a tiny little bit of traveling
not too much so yeah no real big news
other than that so with that spirit in
mind let's go
[Music]
james falcaretto says great podcast on
paleogenetics toward the end of the
discussion the idea of kick-starting
life processes on other planets came up
do you think we are or ever will be wise
enough to evaluate and take that step we
do not have a good track record on such
past intrusions despite whatever good
intentions may have been in play well
you're absolutely right we do not have a
good track record by we i mean the human
race generally um and the question of
the question that came up for those of
you who didn't uh listen to the podcast
this is with uh bachelor gotcha
we talked about the idea not of starting
life on other planets but basically of
if there were other planets we're
imagining very far in the future where
we're visiting planets from other star
systems for example you could imagine
the same question for the solar system
what if there's no life
wherever we are visiting and looking we
decide that you know not mars let's say
but
uh some moon of neptune has no life on
it but it could have life for whatever
reasons you know we can imagine forms of
life that might live there
would we be tempted to
put the raw materials to start life into
that environment to let it go its own
way you know in some sense that's a
minor
intervention you know we're not you know
changing a society or anything like that
or even seeding a planet with life or
terraforming it but we're just giving it
some raw materials that didn't otherwise
have
so
let me uh
first say before answering the question
you know i agree that our intentions are
not always as good as they could be even
when we have good intentions we don't
always do well at following through but
also you know my attitude toward many of
these questions by these questions i
mean
uh should we human beings indulge in
this amazing thing that technology will
someday allow us to do
my attitude toward these questions is
look we're gonna do it right i mean
there's no question about whether we're
going to do it or not human beings
whatever their track record is for
having good or bad intentions their
track record for doing what they're
capable of doing
is almost 100 we do it right i mean we
dropped atomic bombs on cities full of
people that's how human beings roll when
we we derive some new technological
capability no matter how horrific the
consequence is we do it
so when it whether it comes to designer
babies or uploading consciousnesses or
seeding other planets with the raw
ingredients for life i think that our
expectation should be
that we're gonna do it now but actually
in this particular case
i don't think it's that bad i haven't
thought through all the details very
very carefully so i you might be able to
change my mind about this without too
much effort but if there's literally no
life on a planet and we're sure of that
whatever it means to be sure of that
i don't see the harm in putting the raw
materials of life onto a planet indeed i
wouldn't really see the harm in putting
life onto the planet i mean certainly
we're not going to have
that many
uh qualms about visiting and setting up
human habitation on other planets
probably i don't think
um that doesn't mean we should sort of
despoil the entire galaxy or the entire
universe whatever there can be
limitations on what we do
but if it's literally another planet
that doesn't already have life on it i
don't see the harm i don't see literally
who is being harmed
by us doing some dramatic intervention
to it i do think we need to be careful
about it um
it's so far from our experience that
it's hard to think through all the
consequences very clearly but
nevertheless i suspect it's going to
happen and i'm kind of okay with that
peter bamberg says about half of
marriages in the usa and in the uk end
in divorce the promise to stay together
until death do us part appears to be
nonsense in many cases
should marriage be a time limited
contract perhaps renewable rolling
contract what use is marriage all right
someone wants to get their money's worth
with the amas here uh this is a big
question right um
and i don't have any simple answers to
this one either that's probably gonna be
a theme uh through this ama um i'm in
favor of marriage myself i uh am in one
which is extremely successful that
doesn't mean it's for everybody i'm
perfectly
cognizant of the fact that for some
people marriage is wrong even for some
people who get married
it's certainly true that people do also
get divorced
now you could imagine just
confessing to that right admitting it in
other words
stopping pretending that marriage is
forever this is probably what you're
getting at
um i would be 100 on board
if you said that we could
introduce into the institution of
marriage um different levels right
different kinds of commitment some
people might say well we're going to get
married for five years
other people might say we're going to
get married till death do us part either
one is sort of allowed and written into
the contract i can imagine that
um
but i don't i suspect that most people
just want to do it till the death do us
part so to me the more important thing
is to have a mechanism
is for the mechanism to end it
be a lot
easier and simpler and more
straightforward than it actually is you
know the rules are complicated uh
divorce tends to create bitterness and
financial strife and a whole bunch of
things like that
i think that in fact we have some um
feeling that divorce is somehow bad and
therefore if you're going through it you
should suffer you know it should be
difficult to go through it and i'm
against that i think it should be a lot
easier than that and obviously i think
that if only one person wants to get
divorced that should more or less be
enough i don't i don't think that uh you
should be able to force someone to stay
married to you now
you ask what use is marriage and i think
that's a very good question because
there's more than one use that people
have in mind right i mean there's the
sort of romantic role that marriage
plays as a commitment to another person
i think that's a good thing
uh again not for everybody but for some
people it's the right thing i'd be very
open to also not just imagining uh more
flexibility in the institution of
marriage in terms of
uh
the the time horizon that we attach to
it but also the structure you know i'm
very happy to imagine group marriages
obviously gay marriage or whatever i
think i'm 100 fine with that maybe there
could be you know if you read um the
moon is a harsh mistress by robert
heinlein there's all sorts of elaborate
marriage structures like line marriages
where
uh there's a whole group marriage and
when someone dies someone else is
brought in right and the line marriage
can last for centuries you know who
knows
do you call that a marriage or not you
see i think those things are much more
difficult to make work in practice than
in theory but that's okay if it works
for at least one group that should be
enough as far as i'm concerned um anyway
i was trying to say that there is a
romantic reason for
marriage i'm all in favor of that
there's also a legal reason and i
suspect that
a lot of the
weirdness about marriage in the modern
world is because these are two very
different uses the romantic use and the
legal use and the legal use is not
to be taken lightly like in fact it's a
really really good reason to for a lot
of people to get married i have friends
who are not married even though they are
absolutely completely bonded and have
been for many many years and will be for
many many years into the future
and i worry about that a little bit
because in our modern world
if you're married to somebody then your
spouse has all sorts of rights
automatically
when most importantly when one member of
the marriage is ill or dying or died
um the legal control over what to do uh
goes to the other person in the marriage
and so
that is an incentive to get married
absolutely you know 100
and
maybe that should be
separated from the romantic role i'd be
open to that possibility um but there
has to be some equivalent of that and i
think that would be very important so i
i'd be open to imagining
sort of uh the institution of marriage
being one thing and being entirely
romantic and then other sorts of legal
obligations and connections uh on the
market that one could pursue you know
that might be um a more enlightened way
to do things
but you know you have to deal with the
fact that in the real world people are
not that enlightened and people have
strict ideas handed down through
generations about what marriage should
be so i don't see any of this actually
or much of it anyway happening very soon
sumas i don't know how to pronounce your
name sorry s-e-u-m-a-s
mclennan
is it supposed to be sheamus mistyped i
don't know uh says as a non-physicist i
think i can get a bit of a handle on the
number on a number of concepts and
models in physics via analogy diagrams
simpler equations and such but the idea
of a singularity leaves me stumped is
singularity just a formulation of our
ignorance or can it be imagined as a
thing with a knowable nature
you know i think that the word
singularity appears in different
contexts in different physics situations
most famously in general relativity
einstein's theory of curb space time
where a singularity is a place where the
curvature of space-time becomes
infinitely big roughly speaking there's
different kinds of singularities there's
whole books written classifying
different kinds of singularities
but singularities also appear in other
contexts such as fluid mechanics or you
know field theory sometimes
and
usually
the way that a professional physicist
thinks about a singularity is as a place
where your theory is breaking down so i
know that we like to talk a lot about
what happens at a singularity blah blah
blah but you have to understand that
when physicists say those words what
they really mean is
what is happening
in nature
at the location or at the time when our
theory is predicting a singularity so
the more precise formulation is not what
happens at a singularity but what
happens instead of a singularity so i
wouldn't
spend too much time worrying about
singularities actually i've had this
discussion with you know people who do
classical gender relativity or
philosophy of space time or things like
that who sometimes
just spend a lot of work thinking about
classifying singularities dealing with
them predicting them etc and you know my
attitude is but they almost certainly
don't happen in nature so why are you
doing that you're figuring out
implications of a theory in the regime
where the theory is not accurate so
that's not really what i personally want
to spend my time doing
spoonley orange says
you say in the biggest ideas q a number
21 episode where you discuss the
emergence of space-time from hilbert's
base that gravity enforces a kind of
limit on the dimensionality of hilbert
space does this mean gravity has a
direct effect on hilbert's space and
would that be considered
uh would gravity therefore
be considered more fundamental i'm not
quite sure where the question is asking
and would be considered more fundamental
than space-time
um
uh so i i think that the logic is a
little bit not exactly how i would put
it there you know i don't think that
it would be right to say gravity has a
direct effect on hilbert space the right
way to say it is
gravity as a phenomenon in the form that
we know it in the sort of general
relativistic form where it shows up as
the curvature of space-time
should be thought of as something that
arises in hilbert space theories where
filbert's space itself is finite
dimensional so the hilbert space is
always more fundamental than space-time
or anything like that at least in my way
of thinking about it which is you know
it's my ama so i'm going to go with that
right now hilbert space is where you
start so you don't say gravity has an
effect on hilbert's space you say the
following kinds of hilbert spaces can
support theories of gravity other kinds
of hilbert spaces do not and i think
that infinite dimensional hilbert spaces
typically will not have gravity or at
least
it will have gravity in a form where
local regions of space-time still look
like they're only part of the whole
hilbert space they're described by a
finite dimensional piece of hilbert
space
so for example
the anti-dissider space conformal field
theory correspondence the holographic
duality that strengtheners like to talk
about has the following feature the
boundary theory which is a conformal
field theory no gravity
okay
it has an infinite dimensional helper
space no question about that
uh and it also is supposed to correspond
to a quantum gravity theory in
anti-deceiter space okay an anti-sitter
space is infinite
in spatial extent
so
if you think that a read so that's
compatible in other words in the
following way
in the anti-sitter space where there is
gravity
you can say that every region of space
is described by a finite dimensional
piece of hilbert space but there are an
infinite number of pieces that's how
you're allowed to correspond to the
infinite dimensional hilbert space that
is on the boundary so the gravity theory
as a whole has an infinite dimensional
hilbert space but the individual spatial
regions are only a finite dimensional
piece of them
riverside says you interview scientists
coming from around the world that do
amazing work at american universities
yet at the same time the united states
seems to have become a rather
anti-scientific country over the last
years some may say that the american
brand of radical free market capitalism
is driving both trends the fast-paced
scientific innovation and the deep
economic divides in society that make
people prone to populism and mistrust
towards science rationality and
democratic procedures
would you see it this way and is
improvement possible um i think
you know there are ingredients that you
have identified that play
parts that play a role in this syndrome
but i do think it's it's very very
complicated and i wouldn't want to um
buy into any overly simplistic way of
thinking about it you know for one thing
i don't even know that it's true that
the united or accurate to say the united
states has become a rather
anti-scientific country over the last
years this complaint of the united
states is anti-scientific or
anti-intellectual or whatever is a
perennial complaint okay it's been going
on for a very very long time um you know
when i was just starting out uh the big
controversy was over creationism in high
schools okay and nuclear power that was
another big uh
controversy where you know again and
even before that there was you know the
60s and then sort of
folk spirituality and things like that
and all these got complaints that they
were being anti-scientific so i don't
know of any objective way to measure how
anti-scientific we're being and whether
or not it has in fact increased over the
past several years
okay so having said that um i also sorry
i should also say i don't know how to
measure whether or not the united states
is more anti-scientific than other
countries or than other scientifically
industrialized countries or anything
like that so these are impressions but
these impressions
i don't trust them necessarily i mean
maybe they're true i'm not saying
they're not true i just don't know how
to
test them in a value-free objective way
okay
but there's still a question there is
anti-scientific sentiment um
and where does that come from right i
mean whether it's more or less here or
now than in other places or times i
don't know but it's there so where does
it come from and i think it comes from a
lot of different places and you know
even though i just said don't be too
simplistic about it
let me give you my very very simplistic
take on one aspect that i think is
overlooked okay um i don't i don't
you you suggest capitalism as um
a possible cause and again maybe that's
true but i want to emphasize the role of
culture
in this one um you know the the ideas
role rather than the money role because
when you go back to as i said the
debates over creationism in public
schools for example
um i think that scientists were
continually frustrated when they were
trying to argue against teaching
creationism in schools because they were
arguing on the scientific merits
they were saying you know
here are the pieces of evidence we have
for darwinian evolution and for change
of
species over time et cetera et cetera
therefore we should teach this correct
theory in the schools rather than some
incorrect theory
but i don't think that for most people
who are on the other side i don't think
that was the point i'm sure that for
some people who are on the creationist
side they really just looked at the
evidence and came down on that side but
i think that for a large number of
people there were cultural issues at
work in particular
resentment issues you know we're more
familiar with that these days uh in the
populist era than than we did have in
the discourse in like say the 1980s
where i'm thinking of um but it was
still there you know when you have a big
heterogeneous country like the united
states and that's that's why there might
be some american exceptionalism here
the united states is bigger than most
countries um its population is largely
non-native right i mean the people who
are in the united states today are the
overall majority of them not descended
from families who were here in the
united states 500 years ago right they
came from a whole bunch of different
countries uh bringing different
traditions and cultures along with them
and the history within the united states
is complicated especially by things like
the civil war so we have regional
differences
some regions had slavery some did not
and so all of these things mean that
there is a wide spectrum of kinds of
people
living in the united states perhaps a
wider spectrum than in most other
countries you know even other big
countries like india or china big
population wise uh they have more of a
common history than the united states
does if we're thinking about history
stretching over 500 years a thousand
years etc
so what that means is that you know even
though the united states is a country it
has its history
not everyone necessarily identifies with
the rest of the country or with other
parts of the country and so again to be
very simplistic about it and i would
like to see data here too and so you're
welcome to check me but my feeling is
that
sub
populations of people in the united
states
tend to be a little bit ornery about
being lectured to by other
sub-populations okay whether it's you
know economic class or geographic
location or cultural history or whatever
um
people don't want to be told what to
think and how to believe and what to do
and so i think that for a lot of people
to go back to creationism this is the
point i'm trying to make for a lot of
people the desire to get creationism and
taught in schools was not really about
creationism it wasn't even really about
religion it was about
asserting the right
to determine for themselves what they
wanted taught in their local schools
rather than being told by some
government bureaucracy or some academic
elites or even some group of scientists
what to be taught in their schools so
when the scientists came in and said
let me explain to you the truth
this was counterproductive this is
exactly what they were reacting against
so and i think similar
dynamics are at work with um
anti-scientific movements in the united
states today you know kyrie irving the
basketball player okay
is is on the record saying that he
believes that the earth is flat and he
got laughed at for doing this uh but he
got a little bit of a platform because
he's a famous and very talented
basketball player okay
and
why in the world would anyone believe
the
the earth is flat this makes no sense
scientifically and i take it as
a sort of a signaling effort to say you
know whatever you
authorities are going to tell me to
believe i'm not going to believe them
i'm going to be skeptical i'm going to
do my own research right do these
phrases sound uh
um familiar to you in this day and age
um so
the question to ask when someone says i
believe the earth is flat or the
attitude it takes strategy to take is
not
let me assemble for you the pieces of
evidence that tell you the earth is not
flat that's just the entirely wrong
thing to do the thing to do is to say
what makes you believe that
what is it about
the traditional scientific story for
which there is overwhelming evidence
that makes you distrust it
and so i think that
if we want to
decrease anti-scientific sentiment in
the united states and it's something
i'll talk about in future podcast
discussions
we really need to think about empowering
people and making them feel like they're
not being told what to do and what to
think and what to believe by uh people
who are out of touch with them that's a
bigger project i'm not sure how to do it
but that's my that's my simplistic
theory to address that question
robert ruxin rescue says the question is
how can you reconcile the instantaneous
integrated conscious experience of your
brain with a space-like separated
structure
so the point is and robert goes into a
greater detail if you want to look at
the question in the ama but
you have a bunch of neurons in your
brain
and we attribute to that collection of
neurons uh firing signals at each other
something we call consciousness right
but even though neurons are fairly close
together they are still space-like
separated at any one moment of time that
is to say a neuron on one side of your
brain
will
require some time to send a signal to
the other side of your brain even if
that signal moves at the speed of light
which it doesn't quite they always move
slower than the speed of light so in
what sense can we attribute an
instantaneous
notion of integrated conscious
experience and i think the answer is
it's a mistake to take too literally the
idea of instantaneous integrated
conscious experience there is no such
thing
the human brain works at a certain set
of time scales and actually different
parts of it work at different time
scales but none of those time scales is
instantaneous
we think about the world we perceive the
world
in a coarse-grained way and time is
included in that it's not that there's
any discretization of time but we sort
of smear out what we think of as one
moment of time into some finite interval
which might be very small so small that
we don't even notice it but it's just
not true that we need to think about
instantaneous interactions in the way
that a physicist would seriously take
that to make sense of what the brain is
trying to do
the brain is only approximately
instantaneous and that's only on human
scales not on physics scales at all
i'm going to now group two questions
together one is from james nencaro who
says i am puzzled by your conclusion
about the fundamental origin of the
universe and wonder if you could discuss
this further you had a whole podcast on
why there is something to nothing you
don't have an answer in that podcast
except to say the universe just is
you seem to give tegmark's idea
and any other idea um a zero bayesian
prior probability given your conclusion
of no answer but if the universe has a
cause then the cause must end the chain
of causal descent by itself existing
without a cause doesn't pure mathematics
satisfy this
and the other question is by preston
justice
i've recently read a paper on william
lane craig's kalam cosmological argument
blended with the fine-tuning argument
and know that you had a formal debate
with him in 2014 has your position
reasoning changed at all in the past
seven years and can you please briefly
reiterate your counter-argument
um so
the reason why these two things are
grouped together because at the end of
james's question where he says if the
universe has a cause that cause must end
the chain of causal descent by itself
existing without a cause
is very much in line with william lane
craig's column cosmological argument
that is part of the cosmological
argument the conclusion being that this
cause that exists without a cause is god
so first to answer uh james's question
you know i don't say when we ask the
question why is there something
rather than nothing
to say there is no answer except to say
the universe just is what i try to say
is that's not an answerable question
that is not a question that has an
answer okay just because i can
grammatically form a sentence with a
question mark at the end doesn't mean
it's a sensible question to ask about
the universe right to ask about reality
um when you say
what is the largest prime number
the answer is not a number the answer is
no no there's no such thing as the
largest prime number you shouldn't ask
that question right
likewise when you ask why is there
something rather than nothing
the uh question being begged there is
is it sensible to attach a reason why to
the question of something versus nothing
and my answer is no there's no such
thing as the reason why there is
something rather than nothing that's not
the same as saying the universe just is
although it's it is compatible with
saying the universe just is
the other thing is you know you say that
i give max tag marks
cosmological views a zero bayesian prior
probability and so this is this is you
know pushing a hot button of mine and
let me digress a little bit of over this
because
you know a good bayesian doesn't really
give zero prior probability to almost
anything any any logically coherent
ideas because you never know when
evidence might come along and increase
or decrease your credence in those ideas
but very frequently
i will
when asked a question give an answer to
it
right
like uh you know what is the correct
interpretation of quantum mechanics well
it's the many worlds interpretation
right is there dark matter yes there is
dark matter is the theory of natural
selection basically true yes it
basically is now in all of these
of course what i mean is my credence in
those answers is high high enough that
i'm not going to continually footnote
every single claim i make by saying my
credence is high but not precisely one
okay
so for some weird reason
when i talk about ordinary scientific
subjects
people seem to get that you know when i
say
dark matter exists for example
most people understand that what i'm
saying is i put a very high credence on
the existence of dark matter given the
data and information we have and so on
and so on but when it comes to these
sort of um
grand metaphysical slash theological
questions
anytime i state an opinion people
attribute to me
certainty in that opinion even though
i'm not saying i'm certain in that
opinion i never say i gave zero bayesian
prior probability to anything else i've
never said any words like that i said
here's what i think is right that is
what i said
so you know when i say that like i just
said for my uh attitude toward the why
is there something rather nothing
problem probably there is no reason why
there is something rather than nothing
i'm not meaning to attribute any
certainty to it and i think it's
extremely uh you know one should never
assume that just because a person says
something that they're certain about it
because it would be very tedious indeed
to go through life
mentioning your numerical basic
ingredients to every claim that you make
even if that credence is 99 right so no
one does that and no one should expect
anyone to do that so
it is important to distinguish between
making claims which is always a fine
thing to do
and erroneously attaching certainty to
those claims don't accuse people of
attaching certainty to their claims
unless they actually literally say that
that is what they are doing
okay now then we have the bit about you
know causes and chains of events and
also preston's question about the
cosmological argument and you know my
answer has not changed that much since
2014 which is that the whole talk the
whole discourse
of causes and effects is just completely
inappropriate in the context of the
existence of the universe
the idea of causes and effects you know
goes back a long time uh probably goes
back very very far but certainly
attempts at formalizing it were made by
aristotle and so forth but like many
ideas in philosophy and science they
start out as informal folk ideas and
then we try to make them rigorous okay
we try to attach meaning to these
everyday
human inventions so we have causes and
effects in the everyday world no
question about that right um the cause
of me getting sick was i got a bug right
and i got sick because of that because i
wasn't wearing my mask
perfectly sensible set of things to say
but there's no guarantees
that that informal notion extends
to these huge metaphysical questions
that are well outside the realm of our
everyday experience so that was my point
uh
when i talked with william lane craig
and that would be my answer to your
question james um
this whole first premise of the
cosmological argument everything that
begins to exist has a cause
nope
no it doesn't i would respond to that by
saying the notion of having a cause just
doesn't apply to things like the
universe okay
what does apply you might well ask what
applies well i would say that the
sensible thing that seemingly applies is
does
uh
everything that happens obey the laws of
physics
now of course you always define the laws
of physics to include everything that
happens so a better thing to say is is
there some simple universal set of laws
of physics that is working now
that allows for the universe or for all
of existence and all of reality to be
self-contained
and compatible with that simple set of
laws
now we don't know what the ultimate laws
of physics are so we can't say the
answer to that for sure but with things
like quantum cosmology the wave function
of the universe etc we have very good
reasons to believe that the universe can
exist
self-consistently obeying the laws of
physics without any external cause or
support or creator or anything like that
so that's the scientific attitude uh
given what we know about modern physics
claudio slomovitz says i'm wondering if
all the fields that make up the universe
are present everywhere or if some fields
exist only in limited portions of the
universe a raw definition for field is a
physical quantity represented by a
number or another tensor that has a
value for each point in space and time
does a particular field still exist in
regions of space where the value at each
point is zero what if there are fields
whose number whose value is zero at all
points would we be aware of their
existence
so there's two things going on here one
is the first question would a field
exist even if its value is zero
sure
because the existence of a field means
that it could take on other values if
you invented a field that for some
reason
could only be zero that's the only value
you could have then it might as well not
exist you know the whole point of fields
is that they can in principle change and
interact with other fields
so to answer the second part of your
question would we be aware of it if a
field had zero value everywhere well
again it depends on is it a necessary
fact about the field that it always has
zero value in which case no we would not
be aware of his existence and it would
make no sense to talk about such a field
as existing
but if it just happens to have a zero
value in some region but we could bring
it into a non-zero value then we say it
exists even if we don't do that
so it's not just that it exists when it
has a non-zero value but the possibility
that we could give it a non-zero value
by interacting with other fields for
example is enough to say that that field
exists just like the number zero exists
it doesn't need to be a non-zero number
peter solfest says
sorry i shouldn't have said those last i
shouldn't have said that last word it's
gonna that last sentence is gonna make
me sound like a platonist
things that have a value zero
quantities right like um the number of
pennies in my pocket okay the number of
pennies in my pocket could be zero it is
zero in fact right now uh but the
concept still makes sense and you know
we could say that concept exists the
more i'm saying this the more is a bad
analogy fields are special fields having
zero value uh have no trouble at all
here's a better analogy the temperature
is zero in degrees celsius okay that
doesn't mean that there's no such thing
as temperature it just means the value
is zero
all right peter sulfest says when
working through a new idea or cranking
through math what's your preferred
working medium whiteboard chalkboard
tablet paper etc and why
so i generally go back and forth between
three media you know like in many ways
when people ask about my work habits um
i'm you know i just don't have a very
systematic procedure sorry about that
but uh there's something nice about
working standing up at a blackboard or
whiteboard
unlike many of my colleagues i'm not
all that
invested in whether the board is black
or white okay i like whiteboards just as
much as blackboards a lot of people have
a sort of aesthetic preference for
blackboards
i get it but uh that's not me i don't i
just don't care but there's something
nice about standing up and also you can
sort of
see things in front of you and you can
sort of erase and shape things and
that's very nice but the problem is you
can't be very detailed
about it right like you can't fit that
much onto a blackboard so at some point
you got to sit down and write and
traditionally i've done that with pen
and paper but mostly these days i've
switched over to ipad and apple pencil
okay the same sort of technology that i
use to do the biggest ideas in the
universe series is what i do to take my
notes there's pluses and minuses there
the huge minus is
you can't you know set out 20 pages in
front of you and look at them all at the
same time and the access time to
different pages is actually slower on a
tablet than it is uh in person
on the other hand there's a huge benefit
which is that you can cut and paste
that is a huge benefit the other huge
benefit is that i'm walking around with
my ipad
i have every note i've ever taken since
i got the ipad whereas other notes that
i do on paper i tend to like put in a
file and then never take out of the file
ever again
so i think that overall the tablet is
winning a little bit but you know i'm
open to that changing uh down the road
and then finally
um
you know since usually
uh these ideas that i'm working on are
in the context of some hopefully
deliverable product like a paper or book
or whatever
i'm also typing at the computer so i'm
very often you know i have a fodder file
on my computer where there's a list of
ideas that i someday want to write into
papers or books
and
when one of them grows up to be more
than just a paragraph it will get its
own file
in a folder on the computer and i'll
type in you know ideas that will
eventually become an outline and
hopefully eventually a paper that's how
it works so back and forth between uh
some text files on the computer
the tablet where i can write and do
other things and then the blackboard
where you can sort of conceptualize
everything and also talk to other people
the social aspect is very important
joseph williams says
did you expect ligo to detect the
gravitational waves propagate at the
speed of light do we fully understand
why that is so yes i expected that and
yes we fully understand it it's uh
because gravitational
waves are massless
um we understand it mathematically you
can in fact if you buy my general
relativity book you will prove it for
yourself
the wave equation in classical general
relativity looks basically the same as
the wave equation for maxwell's
electromagnetism so remember that
there's nothing special about the speed
of light
there sorry there's something special
about that speed the thing that is
special about it is not that light moves
at that speed there is a special speed
built into the fabric of space-time uh
the speed at which
you can't ever travel the limiting speed
if you are a massive particle or object
uh though it's the relative velocity
between two particles that are both
massive can never be as large as a
certain speed
it just so happens that light travels at
that speed
and you can see that from the particle
point of view by saying the particles
are massless or from the wave point of
view by just looking at the equation
that the waves obey and the equation
that gravitational waves obey is
basically the same as the equation that
light waves of a electromagnetic wave so
by when i say basically it can't be
exactly the same because light
is a spin one wave and gravity is a spin
two wave so different tensor structures
but the differential equation that tells
you how the wave changes from moment to
moment in time and in space those are
exactly the same structure for light and
for gravity so that is exactly what you
would expect
before you ever turned on ligo and it's
exactly what we saw
to change that
to give either light or gravity some
other speed is actually very challenging
given what we already know about those
two phenomena so people sometimes try to
do it but it's very tricky
phil moyer says
i'm still not clear on the relationship
between space-time curvature eg
descender versus anti-dissider space and
the cosmological constant
first how does the cosmological constant
show what kind of space we live in
second what does current research tell
us about the curvature in of our space
good so there's a couple things going on
here one is i mentioned before but i'll
say again there's a difference between
the curvature of space
and the curvature of space time
so the curvature of space time makes
perfect sense uh you know it's something
that we can define the curvature of
space im implicitly means if you're even
going to talk about that that you've
divided space time up into space and
time right so you can assign space a
curvature now in both cases space and
space-time if you're completely careful
about it you need tensors
to
characterize the mathematical structure
of that curvature in other words it's
not just a single number it's a set of
numbers that answer a bunch of questions
about how the curvature of space is
affecting particles moving in different
directions or something some equivalent
physical notion
um but we very very often simplify okay
so we consider spaces or space times
that we call spaces of constant
curvature curvature that is the same in
every direction and the same with every
point and there you go from by making
that simplification from an infinite
number of possible curvatures
different ways that the space or space
time can be curved to a very small
number namely three
either space or space time if it's
uniform if it's if it's constant
curvature can either be zero curvature
positively curved or negatively curved
okay so when you're talking about this
particular distinction descender versus
anti-dissider
usually we're talking about i mean that
means talking about the curvature of
space time not about the curvature of
space and i mentioned this because if in
the real world
we don't live in either dissider or
anti-descender because dissident
anti-disorder are solutions to general
relativity with zero matter in them by
matter i mean any propagating form of
energy including radiation or fluids or
whatever they're empty universes they
are vacuum solutions to einstein's
equation of general relativity the only
non-zero source that you include to get
those solutions is the vacuum energy the
cosmological constant so basically if
you have no matter no energy other than
the vacuum energy then if the
cosmological constant is positive you
get a decenter solution with positive
curvature if the vacuum energy is
negative you get an anti-descender
solution with negative curvature
and if it's zero you get a minkowski
solution with zero curvature and roughly
those correspond to
test particles moving together over time
as a positive curvature as like you're
on a sphere or they could move apart
over time with negative curvature or you
can have zero curvature like euclid
thought about but the space-time version
of that and as you know euclid thinks
that
initially parallel lines remain parallel
forever same thing is true in space-time
in minkowski space okay
so
in that case it's a very simple
straightforward relationship um if
there's nothing in the world other than
the vacuum energy the vacuum energy
tells you which space you're in but as i
started to say a minute ago we don't
live in the vacuum you and i are not
made of the vacuum we're made of
particles okay
so we will asymptotically approach the
vacuum the universe is emptying out
coming closer and closer to the vacuum
and the fact that we think the
cosmological constant is positive means
that we're approaching d sitter space
but right now we're not into sitter
space
um we're in
something that is approximately
homogeneous and isotropic cosmological
spacetime so if you look at the
distribution of galaxies or or
radiation or anything like that on very
large scales it is approximately uniform
that lets us pick out a preferred way of
dividing space time into space and time
and then we can talk about the curvature
of space all by itself and we can say is
space positively curved negatively
curved or zero
and the important thing is there's a
very long-winded way of getting at a
single important point
the curvature of space is completely
independent from the curvature of
space-time
you can have let's say
a positive cosmological constant
so that you will eventually approach
dissider space in a positively curved
universe and yet in the time in the time
period in the era where you still have
matter and energy other than the
cosmological constant your
spatial slices of space time may very
well be either positively curved or
negatively curved or have zero curvature
at all
and in fact in some cases you are there
are there's more than one way of slicing
space time if you were actually into
sitter space if there was no matter if
you were in a vacuum solution where you
had to sit or space time
you could equally well slice it so that
spatial slices were completely flat or
that spatial slices were positively
curved so it's a complicated
relationship overall so just be keep
your wits about you and make sure you
know whether people are talking about
the curvature of space or the curvature
of space-time
nicholas walker says priority question
remember priority questions are you're
allowed once in your life to ask a
question that i will try to answer and i
can't answer every question because
there's too many questions but i will
always try to answer your priority
questions
but you only get one so make it a good
one and nicholas says i recently watched
a program that said that our current
best view on gravity is that it emerges
from some description of the universe
that has no space and time in it at all
in information returned to the universe
from black holes imprinted in radiation
could you help explain this
uh well you know how how much of an
explanation do you need um there's i did
we did a whole episode with neda
engelhardt on this kind of problem on
the black hole information problem so
i'd recommend you check that out if you
haven't already
um but there's a couple of ideas that
maybe got smushed together here a little
bit um there's the idea that the
fundamental description of space time as
you and i know it is fundamentally
quantum mechanical and doesn't start
with space or time at all
or maybe it starts with time but not
space maybe even space but not time like
all these options are on the table
something that is crucially important to
emphasize here is that we don't know
right i mean the state of our current
knowledge here it's all very very
speculative when it comes to these
things so keep an open mind about what
the possibilities are but the point is
that if you take quantum mechanics
seriously the universe is a wave
function and the wave function has its
own status its own existence as a vector
in some giant hilbert space as we were
talking about earlier and so you want to
be able to describe space and time
or at the very least space
as well as all the fields and particles
etc that we're made out of as emerging
from that underlying
hilbert space vector in hilbert space
way of thinking about things
now that's a very sensible
program to follow and i'm very very
interested in that i've written about it
my most recent paper is literally called
reality as a vector in hilbert's base so
you can check that out or my most recent
paper on this topic anyway
um now the implementation of that
how does space-time really emerge from
this abstract notion that's a tricky
thing and that we know even less about
and so when you say
in information return to the universe
from black holes and printed in
radiation well you know maybe but
certainly not necessarily right like
most
information of the universe was never in
a black hole it was never returned to a
universe anything like that that those
sets of words appear in a context where
you have put some information in a black
hole you've made a black hole some
quantum information has fallen into it
and you're asking how it comes back out
and crucial if it does come out at all
which many of us think it does
there seems to be a crucial step in
which
you're not attributing
anything like a location in space to
that information the information is
somehow spread out in a non-local way
and the details there are remaining to
be worked out i wouldn't want to make
you think that it was almost all set so
that's the that's the uh motivation the
philosophy behind it but you know we
don't completely understand it quite yet
so that's all i'd be willing to
explain right now
ben stein says based on your interview
with edward slingerland and your
discussion of taoism and confucianism in
the context of modern neuroscience
do you think these two ancient
philosophies might actually be more
similar interrelated than they seem in
other words my confucianisms call for
self-cultivation
neurologically developed into the action
without intention of taoism
put another way as was hinted on your
show is intense practice of the piano
and study of physics usually necessary
for musical improvisation and physical
intuition
um
honestly i'm not the one to ask about
this so probably i shouldn't even have
tried to answer it but um i don't want
to speak for
taoism and confucianism i'm not an
expert on those things like i have to
disappoint you on that but the reason
why i wanted to answer it was because
you know there is a
a sort of hopeful tendency
or tendency to be hopeful maybe when you
think about competing philosophies
whether they're religions or
more secular ways of thinking about the
world
to say like aren't they all one at heart
and i think that the general answer even
though i don't know enough about taoism
and confucianism to say but i think that
the general answer is no
right like if we were talking about
consequentialism versus deontology
versus virtue ethics
in the realm of ethical and moral
philosophy i think they're really
different and i think that you know not
all religions are really the same um i
think that confucianism
puts has a an emphasis more on the
social aspects on uh working within a
society in a successful way playing your
role
uh you know taking up your place in the
hierarchy and fulfilling the
requirements and the the
intentions of being in that place
whereas taoism is more individual right
it's about more about cultivating
yourself
for intrinsically virtuous reasons and
so
again even though i'm not an expert
enough to say with any definitiveness i
don't necessarily think that they were
sort of going along the same path they
can be compatible in many ways like i
can certainly imagine that being your
best individual self is completely
compatible with playing your best role
in a society um but that's what i don't
really have enough knowledge about to
say whether or not they really are
compatible a real expert would actually
know
bocce a says would you mind describing
your writing process once you've settled
an idea for a book do you follow any
particular system that guides you
through completing it so like i just
hinted at um my process such as it is is
you know kind of chaotic uh kind of
non-systematic i guess would be a better
way of saying it i know that
there's a very popular genre out there
right of
what your writing process should be
kind of a self-help genre or you know
what the great people did and maybe you
can be inspired by that but i think that
everyone's different and i think that
people should be different and their
processes should be different i mean my
wife jennifer is a writer she writes
more than i do and our processes are
utterly different even though they both
come to a successful conclusion i think
in in very different ways so anyway all
that is preliminary to saying i might
have my process but it shouldn't be your
process as to what my process actually
is
you know it's um
unlike other people
i do as much thinking and outlining as i
can
and reading and research and sort of
conceptualizing in my brain before i
write anything so a lot of people will
you know write a lot of rough drafts and
you know just
core dumps free writing get something on
the page uh then eliminate a lot of it
cut and paste it blah blah blah blah
that is not my process i really tried to
think in the most organized way possible
about what i want to say
where i'm going um and then once it
comes to actually writing it so
the downside of that is a lot of my
working habits look like i'm not doing
anything at all
i'm just sitting there um but then
the good part of it is that once i
actually get to writing i don't need to
revise very much because i really have a
pretty clear idea of what's going on
and when it does actually come to
writing like i will typically sign posts
so like i'll write a very brief outline
right and then i'll just go back and
fill in the outline with the words i
want to say
and um
like going along with this with this
philosophy is you know the idea that i
write from the start to the beginning
like i can't imagine writing chapter
seven before i've written chapter six of
whatever it is i'm writing
uh because i have the whole outline in
mind i generally have a title in mind
even though it doesn't end up being the
title but like a person who can write a
book and not know what the title is
going to be that's very alien to my way
of thinking let's put it that way so
very encouraging to people to do it
other ways but you know i have this this
method where the whole thing is
basically in my head before i start
dlp says what is your favorite
standalone science fiction movie of the
past 10 years standalone meaning not
part of a series or set in a larger
fictional universe uh so i don't really
have one and i almost didn't answer this
question uh for that reason i don't have
any i thought i didn't have anything
insightful to say
but then i was thinking about you know
maybe
you know i just don't really keep in my
head a list of top 10 movies or whatever
right so maybe there was some movie the
past 10 years that i just
had forgotten was really great and so
actually you know went back
inspired by this question i looked up
you know what were the great science
fiction movies of the past 10 years
and part of me thinks that uh
i'm not that impressed with any of them
in the past 10 years you know some of
them are very very good there's a lot of
great movies out there
i really liked you know looper the
martian
ex machina gravity in a slightly
different way
um i will confess
that i didn't watch arrival which
everyone says is really good so i should
have to do that at some point in time
but you know all these are in my mind
pretty good but not like super great
they weren't indelibly stamped into my
consciousness like a really great movie
would be or even
super duper memorable so that when
someone mentions them we go oh yes let's
watch that one again right i think
they're pretty good um
yeah and it
maybe it depends on exactly how the
question was asked so 10 years is a
certain criterion
if we included eternal sunshine of the
spotless mind that's outside the 10-year
window but that i would say it was a
truly great movie that impacted me quite
a bit
um
if we included get out as a science
fiction movie
which arguably you could do it's closer
to horror i suppose uh that i think was
a truly great movie um but yeah the you
know so for example but i guess what i'm
getting at is
the point of me answering this question
is
i don't know if it's my part my fault or
the movie's fault that i don't have a a
real favorite here
um
you know it's certainly plausible to me
that it's my fault right that there is
an era of your life when you're in your
teens or your 20s maybe where you're
more impressionable so you see a movie
and it just has a big impact on your
life and then when you reach a certain
age as i now have it's just harder
to see a movie and say oh that was
really a life-changing experience right
um but you know a movie doesn't need to
be a life-changing experience to be good
so i'm not sure that it is my fault to
be honest um so think for example about
looper directed by ryan johnson
which i really liked but he also
directed knives out which i loved i
think that knives out was uh a way more
impressive movie than looper and looper
was good but knives that was better like
that was my favorite movies and um why
like is it just well you know sometimes
one movie is better than another
i kind of wonder this question is making
me wonder whether science fiction
on screen or at least on the movie part
of things um
is is in a lull these days obviously
science fiction commercially is hugely
successful and you know dlp very
specifically said don't include larger
fictional universes uh but we know
there's some very successful large
fictional universes out there but you
know i i'm thinking about these movies
and there is a certain you know
well-troddenness to them in some sense
like we know the moves uh we know the
scenarios there's some individual
surprises but you know okay we've seen
the matrix
you know we've seen time travel movies
and it's a little bit less
truly new and deep in some way
so you know looper was a time travel
movie that was very well done very
competent you know as fun and it was
good as a movie um but the science
fiction didn't really you know blow my
brains away um and knives out wasn't
trying to be a movie that blew my brains
away right it was just a mystery story
with some [ __ ] characters in it but it
was just so good at being that that i
thought it was much more successful as a
movie um so you know yeah maybe
um
the
the science fiction on screen these days
is
is sort of
less
grandiose less important less
significant in some way or maybe it's
just that the really great people are
mostly doing tv these days that's
completely possible right i mean maybe
the the brilliant
screenwriters are doing things like
black mirror and the expanse and uh who
knows foundation might be there at some
point we don't know game of thrones if
you want to include um
fantasy as well so yeah so i don't know
so this this question made me think more
than i expected it to um and i don't
think i'm like missing any great movies
and of course everyone's
feeling about movies is going to be
different so i'm sure that everyone has
very different
opinions about this than i do
emmett francis says what defines
something as a branch of physics your
conversation with nigel goldenfeld
helped me think through this a bit part
of it seems to be just that the same
sorts of models like the ising model
that apply to basic physical systems
also work quite well when describing
higher level systems so is it just that
mathematical models and tools happen to
carry over to other fields
or is there something deeper that
defines something as physics versus
quantitative modeling
so
i thought see i i guess i got confused
by this question because i thought when
you asked what to find something as a
branch of physics that we were
contrasting physics with you know
chemistry or geology or biology or
whatever but then at the end which is an
intrinsically interesting question right
i mean with nigel's um conversation we
used he sorry uh showed us how to use
techniques that you develop by being a
theoretical physicist and put them to
work in studying biology either
molecular biology or evolutionary
biology etc
so the boundaries are fuzzy in that
sense and maybe that's perfectly fine i
don't really care whether we call it
physics or not but then at the end
emmett puts in this uh
thing where he says
is there something deeper that defines
something in physics versus just
quantitative modeling
i don't know what that means so um
so it's not physics versus other
subfields of science but physics versus
quantitative modeling you know
modeling is a part of physics i guess
you know quantitative modeling is a part
of physics you know part of the
scientific method broadly is inventing
hypotheses which you could call models
and then figuring out what the
predictions are of those models
comparing them to the data and so on and
so on so
i got confused at the last bit of that
question physics versus quantitative
modeling the physics versus biology and
chemistry question um you know part of
it part of my answer would be
uh who cares
don't try to reify these artificial
boundaries just do good science and
learn about the world
but there is sort of a human scale
question why do we tend to think of some
things as physics and other things is
not your first
impression or your first guess is well
we think of
simple systems as being physics and once
they become complicated they become
something else right chemistry or
biology or whatever but
complex systems can or complex behavior
can arise from very simple physical
systems
that's the whole point of what nigel was
talking about so
it's not a very cut-and-dried um
criterion and honestly you know
if i think about it i'm not quite sure
that there is a cut and dried criterion
for saying that something is physics
versus some other
way of doing science or other subfield
of science
rebecca lashawa says uh bostonian here
what are some of the things you like to
do when you're in town how do you like
it here in general and how would you
compare it to la so other than the
weather we'll not talk about the weather
like i said i lived here i lived here
eight years uh five in grad school and
then
three in postdoctoral years uh so i know
the weather very well but still it's a
shock to actually go through it um but i
love boston boston is a great city and
i'm a city person in general i think
most cities are great like once you have
a critical mass of things going on uh i
i'm pretty successful at finding things
that entertain me
um right now i'm sort of in the downtown
crossing chinatown area so there are
more
dumpling houses and hot pot restaurants
around me that i can possibly sample in
a finite period of time so but that's
fun i'm going to try
you know overall the food scene in
boston is not that great to be honest
compared to cities like la or new york
or san francisco or chicago um but
boston obviously has a lot going for it
the single best thing look i know i'm
biased okay i'm very very biased i'm not
everybody
but if i were a bostonian the thing i'd
be most proud of is that it's the best
university town around right and we're
including cambridge and for that matter
let's include medford so tufts can get
in there but uh harvard and mit
obviously but also bu and bc and tufts
and northeastern and a whole bunch of
places brand icy and let's include that
um the you know the amount of smart
people
devoting their lives to intellectual
pursuits um
is just amazing here in the boston area
that's my favorite thing and you know
it's not very
original or anything like that but if
i'm being honest that's uh what i like
about it
um
what do i like to do yeah i don't think
that the things i like to do in boston
otherwise are that different than other
places eating drinking going to music
things like that but i'm not doing a lot
of those things because number one i'm
by myself
jennifer is still back in los angeles
and number two there's a pandemic so i'm
not like hanging out in clubs going to
hear music or anything like that
hopefully i'll be able to come back
under better circumstances pretty soon
how would you compare it to la i mean
it's very very different that's that's
the interesting thing even though
they're both cities with an amazing
number of things to do
they're very different
and the the
and in many of the ways uh i would give
boston the edge in some ways because
it's more walkable right or more public
transportationable and that sounds
trivial it's just a way to get around
rather than what you do when you get
there but it has an impact on how you
interact with the city because in la
because you have to drive everywhere
it's hard to find things in la you can't
just like like here in downtown boston i
can walk in some direction and
interesting things will appear
or if i'm walking to some place for some
particular reason i will notice
interesting things that i hadn't
anticipated before right places or you
know stores or whatever whereas in la
you better know where you're going to
find anything interesting you better go
there and then wandering around the
neighborhood is
usually less rewarding in a place like
la there's some specific neighborhoods
that work quite well in in hollywood or
whatever santa monica but um it's harder
in la i think la is wonderful you know
the the uh the fact that the
entertainment industry is centered there
is a wonderful fact about la the weather
is pretty nice i said i said i wouldn't
mention that but um i really really like
la but i know i like boston too which is
why it's fun to spend a couple months
here
ken wolfe says are you familiar with
eric drexler's publications on his ideas
for what sort of capabilities molecular
nanotechnology could eventually bring
about
so you know i i had eric drexler's book
years ago he wrote a book engines of
creation where one of the very early
nanotechnology books um i don't remember
reading it so like i cannot specifically
answer that i know what was in those
books but i wanted to answer the
question because two things um one is
that and i think i've said this before
apologies for people who have heard me
say it before um
tiny tiny tiny technologies are going to
be hugely important in the near middle
term future i think we underestimate how
important they're going to be
nano scale technologies in general are
going to have an enormous impact on
human lives
but
i had this vague feeling that
the biggest impacts are not going to
come from what we traditionally think of
as nanotechnology but from what we
traditionally think of as synthetic
biology
as francis arnold put it the nobel prize
winner you know a lot of good
engineering at the nanoscale has already
been done by nature
and we can use we can use the ideas that
nature has come up with and modify them
for our own purposes
but that's going to be a much quicker
route to
world-changing technologies than just to
build little machines directly ourselves
and in fact we've seen this right we've
seen this with um crispr which we had a
podcast episodes on with theodore urnov
where crispr is something that exists in
nature bacteria invented it and we are
just repurposing it to edit genomes for
ourselves so
i think that the picture that you might
have in mind of like little tiny
machines where machines are literally
made of metal
they look like little tiny miniaturized
versions of robots it's probably not the
right one
the
the the world at that scale of being
really tiny is a different world than
our macro scale and the appropriate way
to be and way to survive and way to
thrive is probably to look more like a
cell than look like a little robot so
nanotechnology will be important if that
includes sort of cellular biology
synthetic biology things like that
madeleine carr asks a priority question
do you think the concept of bergsonian
duration
the experience of live time through the
immediate data of consciousness will
ever be reconciled with scientific clock
time and by what approach
um yes i do um
i i think there's something missing here
that i'm that i'm not getting in the
question so i'm gonna sorry that it's a
priority question i'm gonna give you a
disappointing answer but
uh the approach is by doing neuroscience
and psychology i guess right i see no
tension
between the experience of live time
through consciousness and scientific
clock time there's like almost
no barrier to answering that question i
mean we our brains are made of little
things that obey the laws of physics the
laws of chemistry the laws of biology
and they tick along like little clocks
and they have rates of doing things and
it takes a certain amount of time to do
different things and the collective
behavior of all those little pieces
gives us consciousness
and gives us the experience of living
through consciousness and that is
responsible for our experience of time
so i i don't i mean of course all the
details
are not yet worked out and will take
effort to work out and i don't i'm not
going to predict when they're going to
be worked out um but it's not something
where there's a huge paradox or puzzle
that we see no way of resolving i think
it seems like it's clear how it will
eventually be figured out
luc di giacomo says priority question
i am 25 year old years old and a
software developer a great job i like
well enough yet i want so badly to be
able to learn and work on the
foundations of quantum mechanics if i
were to decide to make that jump where
would i need to begin
um so i'll uh thanks for asking the
question but i'll answer it not just
specifically for you but in more general
um
you know we live in a world where this
is easier than ever has been before to
go from no knowledge of professional
physics to expert level knowledge of it
because
we've always had books but now we have
online courses lecture notes online
talks and things like that so if you
wanted to do something like this i'm not
saying it's easy or even doable but it's
more doable
than it used to be
uh
really what you need you need two things
you need a curriculum so you need like a
list of subjects to learn and then you
need the actual motivation to do it i
mean it's very very easy to say i'm
going to learn all these things it's
much much harder to do it it's like
saying i'm going to lose 10 pounds
that's very easy to say harder to do for
many people in in actual
fact because
it takes a long time to actually hold
yourself to that standard
so you can find curricula online you
know i always point people to gerard et
tuff's website tuft is a brilliant
living physicist nobel prize winner and
he has a website which is called
something like how to be a good theorist
and he gives a very detailed curriculum
that you can go through and learn and he
links
to online lecture notes as well as
textbooks and things like that so you
could just do that it would take you a
long time
but you know there's no royal road to
geometry it takes time um
the only problem with the tufts list is
that there's too much in it like he's a
genius and uh you know a brilliant guy
and and and he's giving you an
overwhelming amount of stuff you need to
learn and so i've often contemplated
making a companion webpage saying you
know instead of how to be a good
theorist like how to be an adequate
theorist where it was sort of the
minimal set of things you need to know i
mean you need to know calculus but you
know how back how far back do you go is
the question you clearly need to know
algebra okay algebra geometry the basics
trigonometry calculus and then beyond
that you need to know
differential equations vector calculus
complex analysis
various techniques within mathematical
physics to solve differential equations
like series expansions and
transforms fourier transforms especially
a little bit of matrix mechanics
linear algebra right and that's the
basic mathematical toolkit and then with
those you learn the traditional
curriculum is classical mechanics
electromagnetism
quantum mechanics
statistical mechanics and thermodynamics
and then options after that but it
doesn't sound like too much right
classical mechanics quantum mechanics
electromagnetism statistical mechanics
and thermodynamics and the options
include general relativity or nuclear
physics or particle physics or cosmology
or astrophysics or biophysics or many
many different things
but all those topics are available
online if you really wanted to do them
so
if i don't know where your starting
point is
start with classical mechanics you know
buy a big textbook you know or or find a
textbook online
physics 101 start reading it see how far
you get
siraj rajan says priority question is
there a physical distance that two
worlds in the many worlds interpretation
have to maintain to stay distinct more
generally can the many worlds occupy the
same classical physical space
so
nope i have to undo the question in fact
there's no such thing as physical
distance between many worlds so it's not
that there is a certain physical
distance they are separated by to become
different worlds there is literally no
such concept as the distance between the
worlds it's the other way around space
lives within each world separately it's
not that the world's lived within space
okay and this is a difficult little
mental jujitsu to wrap your brain around
because we're not used to thinking that
way we used to think about things living
in space
but in quantum mechanics in the many
worlds interpretation
the thing that matters is the wave
function of the universe and that's not
in
space at all space is in it and for each
different world there's a different copy
of space there's no distance between
them because there's no distance there's
no space in between the different worlds
krather lucas says is there more than a
semantic difference between saying our
universe splits and branches thereby
creating more universes
and saying that all the universes in
many worlds already exist but
differentiate over time
so i think that there is a difference so
but you know many people have asked this
question i never actually myself have
thought about it very very carefully so
i'll give you my tentative belief answer
but again subject to updating if someone
explains it to me better um
what do you mean to say different worlds
there needs to be some meaning to that
statement right when are two different
subsets of some big physical structure
different worlds
so i think that the answer is that if
you change the physical situation in one
of those worlds
the other world doesn't notice
right it will never notice you know as
long as it goes on there's no difference
in the evolution of one world if you
start from a different starting point in
the first world okay
that's the nature of things in many
worlds interpretation
if you have a branching event so now you
have two different branches of the wave
function and i imagine again
hypothetically that doesn't happen but
hypothetically counterfactually
putting my finger in there and messing
with the physical situation in one of
those worlds
what happens in the other one and the
answer is nothing there's no observable
effect
very very similar but different you know
different conceptually but but similar
conclusion to
the cosmological multiverse where the
different universes as we call them are
literally just so far away that nothing
that happens in one universe can affect
the other as we've just discussed here
in many worlds there's no distance
between them but they are causally
separated
so if you want to say well maybe all the
worlds were always there
but we just didn't differentiate between
them i don't think that's right because
if you went in and poked one of those
purported worlds before the branching
event happened before decoherence
happened that would be noticeable in the
other parts of the wave function
um so again i'm not 100 sure that's the
best way of thinking about it but that's
how i think about it right now so
open to
modification if someone gives it to me
maxplan says
a while back i think you organized a
series on naturalism called moving
naturalism forward i love those
discussions and learned a lot from them
have you ever thought of organizing
something like that again
so yeah for those of you who don't know
um
back in i think 2012 uh i helped
organize well i did organize it was
mostly me um one work it was one
workshop called moving naturalism
forward
you can find it online all of the videos
are there it's a wonderful thing we just
got a bunch of people in a room and for
three days we talked it was cut short a
little bit more like two days because
there was a giant hurricane that hit
massachusetts where we were so people
had to run away quickly but it was you
know philosophers and physicists and
biologists and neuroscientists all
talking to each other
um
uh richard dawkins was there steven
weinberg was there dan dennett was there
as well as a bunch of former mindscape
guests jen 11 was there alex rosenberg
was there a bunch of other people and we
had a great time great time um
the whole point of it the motivation of
this was
uh so much effort
had been spent in the atheist naturalist
community
in
saying that god didn't exist or saying
that religion was bad or something like
that right
um
a huge amount of effort and
fine it's true i agree that god doesn't
exist
um but okay what are you gonna do about
it
how are you gonna live your life now
that god does not exist like nietzsche
has asked us this question and have we
given a completely adequate answer to it
and i think the answer is no we've not
given a completely adequate answer to it
and part of the evidence is from that
workshop if you look at the discussions
we didn't agree with each other on a
bunch of things okay
um so there's plenty of work once you
say god doesn't exist you're not
finished
so that's why we called it moving
naturalism forward so like let's agree
like zero time was spent arguing about
the existence of god we all agreed that
god didn't exist but okay what's the
meaning of life
do we have free will how should we be
moral right these are the questions uh
that we that we addressed
simon de deo david purple
other mindscape guests who were on there
i'm sorry i'm missing that i'm
forgetting people but anyway
um
yeah i think it was very very productive
it was very interesting to hear people
and it was also productive because
there was almost no agenda right like i
sketched out an agenda like if it's this
morning then we're talking about the
meaning of life
and i would i designated one person to
lead the discussion we just discussed it
was a small enough group that we could
do that and uh you know it worked i
thought beautifully and we never you
know we didn't say we're going to write
a book or anything like that there was
no obligations so it made uh people
willing to go and and so it was very
useful am i going to do it again you
know maybe i don't know i don't have any
current plans it is work
setting these things up you know so i
only have a finite amount of time in the
day so i have to choose what i'm doing
david wallace and i have actually um
thought about doing moving everett
forward
doing a workshop with just a few people
who are all everedians because you know
there's lots of workshops on the
foundations of quantum mechanics but
we're constantly arguing over what is
the right theory of quantum mechanics
and
if if you there's there's sort of intra
ever ready and questions to be asked
which are very very interesting and so
maybe we could do that and you know this
is not to say someone else couldn't have
a theory on moving cubism forward or
moving pilot wave theories forward good
for them
they shouldn't be bothered by talking to
everettians all the time they should be
able to talk to themselves too and i'm
sure there's a million other uh things
so i will certainly be organizing
workshops going forward but i'm just not
sure which ones
tim kennedy says near the very end of a
recent ama you spoke about how you were
leaning away from consequentialism
and more towards deontologism could you
share more thoughts about that
um yeah so
i'm not sure if it's toward day until
the
day ontologism or not but um it's
certainly true that over the past 10
years or so maybe that's a little bit
too many years but
i guess since writing the big picture
which is more like five years ago when i
really needed to sit down and actually
put onto paper some of my ideas about
ethics and meta ethics
um i had already become a little bit
skeptical of utilitarianism and
consequentialism which was sort of my
natural comfortable home in my early
days thinking about morality and so
forth um it's very very compatible with
being a scientist right um
uh as we will talk about on a uh very
soon upcoming podcast there is a
seductiveness to quantitative measures
of things and and uh
clarity uh you know being able to say
this is bigger than that and that's a
wonderful feature of consequentialism
and utilitarianism there's a number
utility and you add it up and you
maximize it what is better than that
whereas deontology is the idea that you
know rather than just maximizing some
consequences of your actions you follow
rules okay and i need to keep including
which i didn't do very well in the big
picture but there's another
uh approach called virtue ethics where
rather than following rules you know
there are some virtues you aspire to you
know being brave and loyal and helpful
and kind or whatever they are and it's
more the aspiring to these qualities
than the following of these rules that
is important
and so
i think that consequentialism is a
natural guess
a natural intuitive starting point for
trying to be a moral person but i just
don't think it works i don't think there
is a number called utility that you can
add up and maximize
um
i am
certainly a constructivist about
morality i don't think the more
objective morality is out there in the
universe to be found i think that we
construct our our moral um theories and
so the question is what to construct and
on what basis do we pick some moral
principles over others and i think
that's sort of a
kind of an agglomeration of some
combination of our intuitions that we're
just either born with or we develop over
biological time
and our
teaching or learning i should say our
experience in the world you know gives
us some impressions and then of course
our intellect our cognition is able to
try to systematize all of these
encourage initial starting points
and
i think that
if if
if you admit
that morality is not objective
sorry let me back up because this is an
important point i should try to get it
right think of someone like peter singer
the world's most famous utilitarian okay
recent whitaker winner
i combined two words there winner of the
bear gruen prize for philosophy a
million dollar prize
um
and very very influential in thinking
about animal rights and and other issues
in the philosophical world so he comes
to some conclusions that most people
think are counterintuitive um especially
about the rights of um disabled people
and mentally handicapped people and
things like that he thinks that the
world would be better off um if we were
i don't want to put words into his mouth
and i'm sure i'm not going to get it
right let's just say he is much more
willing to contemplate
um ending the lives of people who suffer
than uh
many other people are because many other
people have deontological intuitions
where ending lives is bad and peter
singer is a thoroughbred
consequentialist so he says well if
they're suffering then we'd better offer
them not to be here
and
to me
this is an example of
you start with some moral intuitions
like
increasing utility and happiness is good
and you develop a theory on the basis of
that like i'll be a utilitarian but then
you reach a conclusion
that is incompatible with your initial
intuitions and there's a point of view
that says well
so what you know
i've reached a conclusion and i believe
my theory so even though my theory
contradicts my original intentions um i
should believe the theory if i'm going
to be logically consistent and
intellectually coherent right
and that's a that's an attitude that's
peter singer's attitude my attitude is
if the theory leads us to conclusions
that are incompatible with the premises
on which we built the theory that just
means the theory is bad and we need a
better theory and i think that
utilitarianism or consequentialism
always does that it leads you to these
conclusions that are incompatible with
the initial intuitions that you were
using to construct your moral theory so
i'm not sure
what exact replacement i would advocate
for consequentialism but some version of
deontology and or virtue ethics is more
like it
roughly roughly roughly speaking
i mean becoming more fuzzy about
morality uh i'm becoming less and less
convinced that there is a clear crisp
set of rules or principles we can write
down and i think that's compatible with
the idea that we are constructivists you
know the basis the
starting points for our construction of
morality are themselves
unclear ill-defined imprecise so to
attribute perfect clarity and precision
to the outcome is probably a mistake in
some way
um i'm not sure i want to defend that
100 percent but that is roughly
tentatively the direction which i'm
moving
josh hedgepeth says in a cosmos with
infinite worlds where all points in time
are equally real how does one reach a
sense of self are our past and future
selves
or future selves any more us than our
parallel counterparts
so yeah this is part of the important
and weird issue of personal identity in
the many worlds interpretation where
there are parallel worlds with copies of
us in them
and i think you need to update your
sense of self to make sense of many
worlds in a single world cosmology where
things only happen once and we all agree
what those things are and they're all
sort of continuous in space and time
then it makes sense to talk about the
life of an individual person as
constituting a coherent self right
you're born you age you experience some
things eventually you die
uh that makes sense because we all have
that same set of shared experiences we
know what it means etc it would be
complicated if someone builds a
transporter machine we'll talk about
that later um you know if you could copy
yourself and appear somewhere else
and use the old copy of you was still
there now there's two of you well then
the sense of self would would be
different because you're faced with a
different set of circumstances than we
ordinarily are in our experience of the
world likewise if you believe in many
worlds then the reality is different
than our experience we have to update
our notion of what we mean by a single
set of selves
so
i think the sensible way to do it is to
think of
each person on each world as having a
self and the
the
wrinkle the complication
is that if you have multiple people on
different worlds who came from a single
past self
then they share a universal past a
common past but they don't share a
common future the things that will
happen to them in the future are
distinct
so that change the fact that they
do not share a common future to me means
they're separate people okay
that would certainly be the case if you
made a duplicate of yourself and the
duplicate was very far away and the
duplicate was living their own life and
they were experiencing their own stuff
completely different than what you were
experiencing there's no sense whatsoever
in which that's also you or the same as
you or part of one collective you right
even though
you share the same past your futures are
completely different that's the
situation in many worlds
happily in many worlds unlike the
duplicator machine um we're never going
to see those other people so it just
doesn't at all matter right i would
advocate that each one of them is a
separate self but it also doesn't matter
as long as you don't sort of try to
group yourself into some collective
being
the fact that more copies of you will
split off and live in different
universes is irrelevant you personally
any one of those individual copies
can think of themselves as having a
unique past and a unique future it's
true about the unique past the future
it's not true but for all intents and
purposes it is so i think that even
though you need to change the words
around a little bit
the actual uh operation of the sense of
self isn't any different in many worlds
than it usually would be in a single
world cosmology
marion marcali says i was listening to
the latest complexity podcast with brian
arthur on economics by the way i should
say
you mean the latest podcast episode of
mindscape but there is an a whole
podcast called the complexity podcast
put out by the santa fe institute which
you might be interested in checking out
okay question continues basically the
theory is so abstract and divorced from
the world and this makes it very
successful in some aspects but too
disconnected and unable to actually
model reality correctly it should be a
more complete dynamical process more
algorithmic computational in nature
it seems maybe mathematics and physics
are in the same situation with many
disconnected fields or tools or theories
but not a central core is this way of
thinking applicable to physics maybe
hyper graphs are the underlying topology
for the qft equations or something like
that
um
so i'll put aside whether i quite agree
with your
way of talking about what brian said
vis-a-vis economics um
i mean economics is very the the theory
the standard theory of economics as it
currently exists is successful at some
things less successful than others and
complicated to draw the line between
them
but for physics i would say the answer
is no this is not a good analogy or it's
not the same situation anyway
physics has
shared underlying
theories and methodologies right the
standard model of particle physics
underlies all the different areas of
physics if you have a physics theory
of you know i don't know atomic physics
okay you have a specific thing going on
in atomic physics
and it violates the rules of the
standard model of particle physics then
either you're wrong or you're going to
win the nobel prize there's no sense in
which you just go on and say yeah well
it's a different field right
they're all sharing that same common
core and furthermore the methodologies
and the
standards and the questions that are
interesting are more or less common
physics is remarkably unified you know
considering how much ground it covers
and that comes down to the fact that
physics is pretty simple compared to
other things physics is all about
simplifying things as much as we
possibly can and other sciences other
areas of science don't have that
don't have that privilege
okay i'm going to group two questions
together
one is from austin hughes who asks a
priority question well quantum
mechanical behavior is very different
from our everyday experience but the
theory is incredibly good at making
predictions how confident are physicists
that this is a real description of
reality or an emergent phenomenon may be
from some lower level description of
reality is it ever possible to say that
a theory is the lowest level description
of reality versus the description of an
emergent phenomenon
and then the other question is from sid
huff who says
do physicists know for certain that
quarks are not made of something even
smaller and why so you see sid's
question is a more specific version of
uh austin's question
and the answer is we don't know you know
we
we arguably will never know for sure
whether or not
our current best theory of the world
is
the fundamental theory is the absolutely
correct theory you have to be
open-minded about the fact that you
might discover some new phenomenon that
you didn't predict in your underlying
theory
but what we do know is that right now we
don't have it we do not have that
underlying theory of everything because
we have general relativity and we have
quantum mechanics they're incompatible
with each other
you would think that different parts of
physics are need to be ultimately
compatible with each other because they
all are describing the world in some way
it might turn out that the best
description of the world uh is a
patchwork quilt where the patches
overlap with each other but they can't
be
incompatible in regions where they
should both be true and that's the
current situation with general
relativity and quantum mechanics so
you know we can look for ever deeper
levels but the point is not there is a
level that is the deepest and we need to
find that right if we keep finding
deeper levels that's fine if we find a
level that seems to be
a theory that covers everything that's
also fine and we can also keep looking
for even deeper levels after that the
specific question
for quarks
um
people have absolutely thought of the
idea that quarks are made out of smaller
constituents in fact there's even a name
for it it's the idea of a prion p r a e
o n not a primon which is a neuroscience
concept uh prions are hypothetical
little particles that are inside quarks
in some sense so you can try right you
can try to build a model of prions
inside quarks compared to the data et
cetera doesn't seem to work as far as
anyone knows it doesn't really work yet
maybe we just haven't been clever enough
yet um but i think that the smart money
is betting the quarks really are
fundamental at least as far as field
theory is concerned
abby levine says it seems that space
expands everywhere except eg in galaxies
is it that interstellar expansion is
negligible compared to intergalactic and
larger scales or is it literally zero
so of those two options it's closer to
saying it's literally zero but there's a
more subtle answer here
when we talk about the expansion of
space
we are talking about cosmology and in
fact we are specifically talking about
uh the approximation we use in cosmology
that you can divide all of space time
as we said before into space and time
assign a geometry to space and talk
about how that geometry of space changes
over time and since the assumption is
that the universe is homogeneous it's
the same everywhere in this
approximation we're making that
assumption it's the same curvature of
space everywhere and it either just
increases or decreases
and we call that the expansion of the
universe or the contraction of the
universe if that were to happen
but of course we know that in the real
world that's just an approximation and
that approximation breaks down when you
get to the level of inside a galaxy
inside a galaxy it is it would be a
terrible approximation to think that the
density of the galaxy is the same as the
density of the universe or intergalactic
space
so the real point is that the metric of
space-time inside a galaxy
is not
in any sense well approximated
by attributing a constant curvature to
space
the curvature is different in different
places it's different inside the sun
outside the sun inside the black hole
far away from the galaxy near the rim of
the galaxy
uh where the gravitational wave is
passing by whether two neutron stars are
orbiting each other all these weird
crazy things are happening in a very
very
location-dependent way
so the idea that there's one thing
called the curvature of space that has a
number that either increases or
decreases is just wildly inaccurate okay
so inside a galaxy it's and this is a
more full answer that i've ever given to
this question i've been answered this
question lots of times is the fullest
answer i've given to it
it's just conceptually wrong to talk
about the expansion of space what you
should talk about is the curvature of
space-time
in the galaxy okay and that you can do
and it's it's complicated because
there's lots of stars and lots of
gravitational fields but remember the
curvature of space-time is what gives
rise to what we think of as the
gravitational field so when you're
talking about the space-time curvature
within a galaxy
need to separately treat every star and
planet right because they're all sources
for space-time curvature
now having said that so this is all a
way of saying you really shouldn't even
talk about the expansion of space inside
a galaxy
but there's also an additional bit of
intuition that you can get
which is the following if you take an
expanding universe which is completely
smooth and homogeneous
and take a region of that universe
imagine that it's like made of dust dust
is what cosmologists call particles that
are not moving okay individual particles
scattered uniformly through space but
they're not moving with respect to each
other so space is expanding the
particles are moving apart
take all those particles in a spherical
region of space
and squeeze them into the center of that
spherical region leaving a gap leaving
empty space in between the center of
that region where now you've made a
collection a clump and the rest of the
universe going on its own way you can
exactly solve einstein's equation for
this kind of situation where you have a
clump of stuff
orbiting itself much like a galaxy
and then you have a region of empty
space a spherical annulus around that
clump and then past some boundary you
have a uniform collection of matter the
uniform collection of matter continues
to expand it is unaffected by a
spherical concentration of matter
replacing a spherical region of uniform
dust okay
and
the galaxy that you made the clump of
particles
is completely unaffected by the fact
that the rest of the universe is
expanding a hundred percent zero
unaffected there's literally no it's not
an approximation it's not pretty close
it's not negligible it's a zero effect
of a spherically symmetric expanding
universe around it
so
to the extent that that thought
experiment is a more or less useful
guide to what happens
in real galaxies as if we consider the
rest of the universe outside the galaxy
as still being completely smooth and
homogeneous but inside where a clump of
matter surrounded by empty space
there is zero effect of the expansion of
the universe on what happens inside a
galaxy and that's more or less true in
the real world in our actual galaxy
alexander cordova says
if you were close enough to two
colliding black holes or neutron stars
would you be able to see the
gravitational waves rippling off i'm
guessing the time scales here may not be
human friendly but assuming we could
take a video and play it backward could
you could and play it back and fast
forward or slow motion could you
actually see the ripples moving outward
uh no certainly not it's gravitational
waves the only thing you can ever see
are electromagnetic waves that's what it
means to see you're looking with your
eyes that see light and a gravitational
wave puts off zero light if you
surrounded the
in spiraling objects with other objects
you know planets or stars or whatever
then you could see that they would move
with respect to each other but you're
looking at those planets and stars
you're not looking at the gravitational
distortions directly
jeff b says i would love to be able to
dive deeper into physics and many other
challenging subjects but i find that i
lack the energy after coming home from
work do i just need to suck it up and
get reading or is there a way to make
learning challenging concepts feel like
less of a chore
um
mostly you gotta suck it up i think is
the answer here i don't think that there
aren't any tricks
to making learning challenging concepts
uh any easier when you say that it feels
like a chore
um
you know that
what does that mean exactly because you
just said you'd love to be able to dive
deeper into it but then you say it's a
chore
so you know maybe it is just a chore
maybe it's not
something that you're really interested
in diving deeper into maybe you just
wanted to have happened
and there's just no way to make that
happen because when you're learning
something like this you're retraining
your brain your brain doesn't naturally
go down those routes that you need to go
to learn about modern physics or any
other academic subject really so it's
hard and it requires you know practice
and thought and also repetition doing
problems you know working out things for
yourself et cetera et cetera
you know you can do it in bite-sized
chunks rather than trying to do it all
at once you know you need to if you're
learning as we already talked about the
curriculum right classical mechanics
electromagnetism etc
and every one of those subjects of
course has many sub subjects okay
if you if you think of learning a little
bit of a sub-subject as a goal in itself
rather than saying i just want to learn
all the physics that's that's too much
you know break it down into smaller
pieces and then maybe you'll feel a
sense of accomplishment when you just
get a little bit into it it's the best i
can offer
casey mahone says david eagleman had an
idea i thought was fascinating to be
clear he did not claim to believe it the
idea is that the brain is analogous to a
radio if you only studied the radio
itself you would never be able to
understand where the sounds it made were
coming from so maybe consciousness works
in a similar way where we can never
understand it simply by studying the
brain
to preempt your possible response we
should be able to detect the presence of
any consciousness field that pervades
space but perhaps the brain is reading
some type of signal that appears
scrambled or encrypted unless
interpreted by a brain-like structure
so you know in in
as usual the answer is anything's
possible you know maybe uh david is
describing not a new idea but an ancient
one i mean this is the idea that not
ancient maybe it is ancient but it's
certainly very old this is descartes
idea
you know descartes was a card-carrying
dualist he thought that the mind was
completely separate from the body and
was indeed not even physical or located
in space at all
and he had this idea that there was a
radio receiver he didn't call it that
but basically a radio receiver in the
pineal gland in the brain that
communicated
thoughts and feelings to and from the
mind and the actual body
it doesn't work for lots of reasons for
many many many reasons but the simplest
one today is that as i've often said we
know too much about the physics of the
particles that make up the brain uh in
order for something like this scheme to
work even if it's encrypted etc etc you
have to change the laws of physics
and we have very very good experimental
data that says that the laws of physics
when it comes to atoms and electrons and
molecules etc are very very well
understood again it's possible but
there's zero evidence for lots of
evidence against it
joshua hillerup says how common is it
for physicists working in your area
these days to discover facts about the
universe that get basically confirmed as
being true where on the spectrum is it
from every working physicist should be
doing this fairly often two if you
manage to do this you win a nobel prize
well i think the key phrase here is in
your areas in most areas of science
working physicists do discover new facts
about the universe the facts might not
be that profound right like if you have
a new material
that you made out of atoms in a certain
new crystalline configuration and you
measure its tensile strength or its
electrical conductivity boom you've
discovered a new fact about the universe
okay
real physicists and real biologists and
chemists etc do things like this all the
time that's their job they discover
these new facts about the universe now
these facts are not
facts about fundamental physics as we
like to call it
or elementary physics if you want to be
a little bit more
uh humble about the whole thing the
basic laws of nature right the core
theory the standard model of particle
physics plus general relativity
that is something that's been in place
since the 70s um the only
things we've done since then are
discover parts of it you know so we've
measured the mass of the higgs boson but
the higgs boson idea was invented in the
60s
we measured the cosmological constant
right the vacuum energy we thought it
was zero but we discovered it so we knew
that it could be there it was just it
was proposed by einstein in 1917
uh but we measured its value a lot of
people thought it would be zero
and likewise masses of neutrinos are
something that sneaked up on us
gradually you know through the 70s 80s
90s and now we have some more data about
them but the basic structures that
allowed all this to happen have been
there since the 70s or earlier
so no people in my areas do not discover
new facts about the universe um to
discover a new fact about the
fundamental laws of physics is something
that you know
if it goes on like this
soon all the people who have done it
will no longer be with us steven
weinberg did it right as a theoretical
physicist he discovered how to unify
electromagnetism with the weak nuclear
force but he passed away recently so yes
these days in fundamental physics if you
discover a new fact about the universe
you would absolutely win a nobel prize
siddhartha says it's been a while since
i last saw you in a theism versus
atheism debate on youtube do you think
the ideas and arguments supporting
atheistic worldview are so sufficiently
widespread today you don't need to
anymore or did the debate format stop
being that interesting and effective
um a combination but i think also i just
haven't been invited to any i don't
think there are that many like i don't
set up these debates you know i have a
mixed feeling about public debates um
it's not really a way to um
reach any conclusions right when i
participate in one of these debates
i'm not trying to win the debate i'm not
trying to score points and and come out
on top on some judge's ballot nor am i
trying to persuade the person i'm
debating because usually they're very
very very set in their ways as to be
fair i'm very sad in my ways if i'm
actually having a debate about these
things what you want to do is reach the
audience there are people in the
audience who have not made up their
minds about these questions so i think
that there is a useful purpose to these
debates but it's not finding the truth
it is educating the audience about ideas
you already have um
look i'm busy i give a lot of talks
things like that uh recently the talks
that i've been invited to give have not
been debates they've just been talks i
have no objection to the idea but you
know i've said a lot of what i want to
say in that format so um it would have
to be interesting for some reason for me
to do it again
charlie grover asks a question about um
the swamp land so it's a long question
i'm going to try to make it a little bit
shorter but he says kumar and valfa
another prominent string theorist i've
recently been working out
working a lot on these swampland
conjectures and so to put in my own
words the idea of the swampland is
we have this idea of low energy
effective field theory okay so we have
field theories including the standard
model but also extensions of the
standard model you can include super
symmetry or dark matter or whatever all
of these are low energy effective field
theories they're not supposed to be
theories of everything the theories of
particle physics and quantum fields of
low energies
and there's millions of them an infinite
number you can easily invent the
swampland conjecture says that
not all theories of low energy particle
physics that you can invent
can be derived or can be made compatible
with quantum gravity and in particular
string theories because they think the
quantum gravity is string theory
generally people who do this so the
swampland language was invented to
contrast with a landscape okay the
string theory landscape is this set of
very large number
numbers like 10 to the 500 are bandied
about but we don't really know very
large number of possible low energy
theories that you can derive from string
theory and the idea behind the swampland
conjecture is well if there is a finite
number
that you can or even if there is a sort
of
uh parametrized finite dimensional set
of theories you can derive from string
theory and there's a whole bunch of
other theories you can't
and maybe we can learn something about
um either string theory or about nature
by understanding the difference between
these and sorry i'm putting words in
charlie's mouth sorry about this but um
the question he focuses in on is that of
the cosmological constant it has turned
out to be extremely hard within string
theory
to come up with low energy effective
field theories
where the cosmos constant is positive so
remember
string theory starts as a theory of
strings or maybe a theory of membranes
or things like that but in a higher
number of space-time dimensions either
10 or 11 depending on the version or the
limit that you're taking in string
theory but more than four that we live
in so you have to compactify these extra
dimensions and when you compactify the
extra dimensions
it affects all the parameters of your
low energy theory the mass of the
electron the charge the fine structure
constant and also the vacuum energy
and so far
not only have we not
rigorously established the existence of
some compactification of the extra
dimensions
which leaves the cosmological constant
positive
there are general arguments that you
can't
now these general arguments are not
airtight so there are other people
um there are people i should say who
have claimed to suggest ways you can
make compactifications of string theory
with a positive cosmological constant
there is a famous paper called kklt
after the initials of its authors
um
uh if i can remember correctly katru
kalosh
linde and tribetti um
and then many follow-up papers from that
where they propose that they could do it
they could get a combactification of
string theory with a positive cosmos
constant
others don't think it works they
disagree with this paper okay so despite
it being theoretical physics there's
room for disagreement there okay so all
this is a long warm-up to saying
that there are still string theorists
who think that string theory is
incompatible with the positive vacuum
energy full stop in the low energy
effective field theory and you might say
well
then string theories ruled out because
we've measured the acceleration of the
universe and the cosmos constant is
positive
but not so fast
there is of course the possibility that
the acceleration of the universe is not
due to the cosmological constant but due
to a dynamical form of dark energy right
sometimes
the leading candidate would be
quintessence would be a scalar field
slowly rolling down a potential um
now i've written about quintessence i
thought a lot about it back in the day
i was the first one to really um
emphasize the fact that if you have
these quintessence fields they should
couple to other fields they should
couple to the standard model fields and
be detectable for that reason
um but i also
pointed out the loopholes in that
argument how you could construct
quintessence fields that were not
detectable
but generally you know if quintessence
were the dark energy it would have been
easy to already have detected it to
already have either measured it directly
through couplings to other fields or
indirectly through the expansion of the
universe and we haven't yet so whatever
your credence is in quintessence versus
cosmological constant it's lower now
than it was
20 years ago when we started playing
these games
so the question charlie's question is
what about this theoretical argument
from string theory which leaves open the
possibility of quintessence but seems to
be against the cosmological constant um
so i don't take it very seriously that
particular argument honestly um
i and i don't know enough about it to
really be qualified to take it seriously
or not but i my impression is
that the game being played of looking at
compactifications of string theory is a
sufficiently hard game to play
that making these very very general
statements about what isn't is not
possible is a bit premature
so i'm not at all convinced that string
theory really is incompatible with um
compactifications that give you a
positive vacuum energy so it hasn't
changed my credences that much
but you know look i'd be delighted if
the dark energy were uh quintessence in
fact as i previously mentioned very
briefly um
if it's quintessence that is a
pseudo-scalar field that could cause
cosmological birefringence and i'd be
famous because i predicted that
so my vested interests are in favor of
it but you know i i love the idea of the
swampland program because it is a real
good faith honest attempt to connect
string theory to observational and
experimental physics
and however you can do that is a good
thing
vladislav
i hope i got that right
asks a priority question what would be
your credences that there are horrible
inner experiences associated with a
person who is having surgery under
successfully applied general anesthesia
assume there are inner experiences
associated with conscious people and
maybe you mean unconscious people
oh no maybe you mean conscious people
you just mean i assume that inner
experiences are real things
and there are no inner experiences
associated with dead people without
brain activity um
i think my my my credences would be
pretty low because we have some data
namely dreaming right
dreaming is not exactly the same as
being under general anesthesia but
it seems perfectly plausible to say that
in the absence of other data
whatever
experiences we have when we're not
conscious
might be very much like or at least bear
family resemblances to the experiences
we have when we're dreaming
what i really expect is the general
anesthesia and again not enough of an
expert to have a firm opinion about this
but my feeling would be the general
anesthesia puts you under so deeply that
you don't have experiences right you
don't have anything that you would
recognize as an experience just as you
don't when you're asleep and not
dreaming that you can be asleep and not
dreaming right um so together with the
fact that i think there probably are no
experiences when you're under general
anesthetic and whatever experiences you
do have i i'm guessing are more
analogous to dreams than to horrible
tortures
my credence that there are such horrible
inner tortures is pretty small
and i should say you know obviously the
um
potential benefits of surgery to your
waking self could be very very large so
i wouldn't
use this as an excuse to
not put yourself under general aesthetic
for important surgery maybe
considerations like this
are you know
make you think twice about
uh elective surgery but look you know as
with always with these arguments that
seem to be low credence
focusing on low credence possibilities
there's also the possibility you have
blissful nirvana experiences under
general anesthetic right and you'd be
depriving yourself of those by not going
under so i'm not quite sure where to
balance that out
alexandra zhani says you've said we have
reason to be confident the laws of
physics underlying the phenomena of
everyday life are completely known but
you and others have written books about
a variety of physical phenomena we do
not fully understand yet and so the
specific arrangements of the particles
in those books is caused by said poorly
understood phenomena so don't we need
more physics to fully explain the
arrangement of particles in the everyday
phenomena of many physics books uh sure
obviously
i've never said that physics is done
i've never said we don't need more
physics what i said is the kind of
physics that we need is not of the form
laws of physics underlying everyday life
at the level of the core theory of
quantum field theory
that part of physics is done
the way that those core fields come
together
to make complicated things like books
and people obviously completely unknown
or not completely unknown but very far
from being completely established and we
have a lot of work to do on that those
two statements are utterly compatible
oria bittel says
in your podcast with neil ferguson he
mentioned the fact that it is easy to
place all the blame on individual actors
for failures to meet demands during a
catastrophe and instead he opted to
emphasize the role of networks and how
our lack of native
native vigilance can cause dysfunction
in regards to covid however he seemed to
be downplaying the role that one man
donald trump material had in
politicizing and therefore swaying the
republican response and messaging around
the crisis
is it not valid to blame the spearhead
as a useful shorthand when trying to
troubleshoot how best not to repeat
these same errors
well so i think a couple things are
going on here i mean one neil is not
being inconsistent right he says he's
saying it's we're too tempted to blame
individuals uh and in this case he's not
blaming an individual so that's
completely consistent now what you're
suggesting is maybe there is a sense in
which we should be blaming an individual
in this case
and um regardless of the uh specific
details of this moment in history i
think as a general question can
individuals
be blamed for bad responses to
catastrophes
you know i think it's a complicated
question because i think that this is in
the nature of complex systems i think
that probably i'd be sympathetic to the
direction of neil's critique namely that
we are
more likely to blame individuals and
less likely to blame systems
than we should be
i don't think that that means we should
not blame individuals at all right
the system of which donald trump was a
part
is very complicated there's a lot of
inertia in it and a lot of moving parts
and there's only so much that one person
so much impact that one person can have
even the president of the united states
you know um having said that
some people have a lot more impact than
other people do and powerful politicians
and business people etc have more impact
have more power in this system and it is
100 okay in my mind to blame them for
the responsibility um that they deserve
to have
so you know that's all those are all
fuzzy words and there's a quantitative
question of how much blame took place
but you know i am sympathetic with the
general idea
that too often we personalize the blame
because it's much easier
um emotionally to place blame on a
person than it is on institutions and
and systems
stuart haynes says
when i sort your youtube videos by views
i see that many of the biggest ideas in
the universe videos have the most views
did you think that series would be that
successful and which of your videos have
been the most surprisingly popular or on
the other hand surprisingly not so
popular and why
i mean basically
my my videos on youtube fall into four
categories one category is the biggest
ideas series which has like i don't know
48 videos uh one is the mindscape um
podcast which
i put on youtube as a favor to the
people of youtube and i get you know
like 5 000 views it's not a lot
um but it's exactly the podcast and
there's no video it's just an image a
static image and i have no reason no
understanding of why people would rather
listen to the audio
on youtube rather than on some podcast
app even if you're sitting at your
desktop
you can listen to the podcast either on
preposterousuniverse.com or on apple
podcast or whatever but some people
really like youtube okay that's fine
um then they're the only other long
series of videos i did were the moving
naturalism forward conference videos i
mentioned this this workshop we did
and um
we videoed all that and that's all been
edited very nicely by geomora and has
been put on
the web in bite size chunks and um and
finally like there's a couple of
miscellaneous videos that are not really
worth even mentioning so
um i'm not all surprised that the
biggest ideas did much better than the
mindscape videos because look the
mindscape videos i i didn't i don't get
any benefit from this extra work for me
i don't even get paid like when someone
listens to the video oh sorry listens to
the podcast on a podcast app
uh my podcast
host or not host my podcast network
wonderee counts that as a download and
it charges the advertisers and so i get
a penny or whatever it is uh for every
one of those times that someone listens
on a podcast app i get
i do not get
money from the advertisers on youtube
when someone watches on youtube um i do
get money from youtube ads but that's
like an order of magnitude less youtube
is not
you're not doing youtube for the money
at my level like once you get millions
of hits then maybe doing
uh youtube videos uh is worth your while
but for five thousand hits it's really
not you're not you know buying an ice
cream cone for that much less quitting
your job um
so i just do it because i know that
people like
doing it on youtube and i want the
podcast to reach as many people as
possible that's why i do it um but i
wouldn't watch mindscape i wouldn't do
minescape on youtube i would do it on a
podcast app so i'm not at all surprised
that the biggest ideas videos which were
meant to be seen on youtube and have
visuals do much better than the
mindscape videos
i do wish that the moving naturalism
forward videos had done better they did
very badly in terms of numbers uh and
i'm not sure why you know we had famous
people there saying interesting things
and uh the videos themselves where i
think very nicely done hired a
professional videographer and so forth
um so i think there's a lot of treasures
in there that haven't been appreciated
by uh the wider folks
lineau mizyara says how does david
wallace's explanation for probability in
many worlds differ from yours
well i think it's ultimately completely
compatible um you know chip stevens and
i wrote a paper a couple papers on
probability in many worlds using
self-locating uncertainty and we
emphasized from the start that we
weren't doing it because we thought that
other people's explanations were wrong
if there's one true fact
it's very often the case you could
explain that true fact in different ways
using different words but still be a
true explanation in some sense right
um
having said that they're sort of
um
you know in feel they feel very
different and the reason why
i like ours is because it's sort of not
just gives you the right answer but in
my mind it gives you a better feeling
for why there is probability at all
in some sense you couldn't possibly get
the wrong answer if you put in a good
faith effort to understand probability
in many worlds the only thing you're
ever going to get out is the bourne rule
it's just the only thing that makes
sense over you know consistently over
time and things like that and had all
the probabilities add to one et cetera
you're gonna get the born rule the real
question is why
you have probability at all
and the
approach that david wallace has that was
based on ideas by david deutsch
is very very
instrumentalist in some sense you know
the idea is look here we are
in quantum mechanics in fact deutsche's
original paper doesn't even really
necessarily need many worlds he just
needs quantum mechanics
and he says if there were
well basically sorry i don't want to go
into it's getting late uh i don't want
to go into too many details here but his
idea is that
if there are outcomes for quantum
mechanical measurements that you value
differently you'd be happy if the spin
was up less happy if the spin was down
then what you could show is that using
decision theory
which says that you know among other
among other um assumptions of decision
theory
if you play games with probabilities
you should be just as happy
with playing a game that gives you 100
probability of giving you value 1
as you should be with playing a game
that gives you 50 probability of value
zero and fifty percent probability of
value two
now you might say well no i'm risk
averse i like getting the one with 100
probability rather than the 50
probability of getting two but that's
because you're not really appreciating
the word value here value doesn't mean
money
value literally means that you value two
the the meaning of the phrase value two
in decision theory is
you give fifty percent chance of value
to equal
value as 100 chance of value one that's
what it means okay and what deutsch
argues and what david wallace follows up
to fill in some of the details and make
it a little bit more rigorous
is that given that there are
probabilistic outcomes in quantum
mechanics decision theory tells us that
we should act as if
the probability of getting different
outcomes obeys the bourne rule okay
so
that's great i mean that's absolutely
100 compatible with how i think about
decision theory and quantum mechanics
and many worlds we should act as if
there is really a truly stochastic
process with a probability given by the
born rule okay
but it doesn't really scratch the itch
of saying i want to know why there's
probabilities at all
and uh chip and i following on ideas
from lev weidman
pinpoint where the necessity of
probability is namely in the
self-locating uncertainty that you don't
know which branch you're on and all the
words we use and all the metaphysical
moves we use sound very different than
the deutsche and wallace construction
but they get the same answers
um so they're compatible but i think
that
ours is a little bit more satisfying at
explaining why you should think about
the world and probabilities at all
theirs is extremely extremely good at
saying if you do think about many worlds
in terms of probabilities it better be
the bourne rule
brad malt says in something deeply
hidden you present a socratic dialogue
between alice and her father in which
they debate whether the number of worlds
is finite or infinite and conclude the
answer is not known can you explain how
the answer could be anything other than
infinite for example the probability
distribution associated with many
wavefunctions is a continuous curve like
the position of two electrons
since an infinite number of points can
fit on a continuous curve when the
wavefunction collapses an infinite
number of worlds must be created
so yeah
but you've assumed a model of electrons
namely you've assumed that the electron
uh can be classically described as a
point particle moving in a continuum
and that might not be true indeed in
quantum gravity it wouldn't be true in
quantum gravity uh if what we said
before about the dimensionality of
hilbert space is correct
um
the treating fields and particles as
living in a continuum is just a good
approximation valid at low energies it's
not exactly true i mean
consider that when you actually measure
the position of an electron you don't do
so with infinite precision right a real
measuring apparatus has some error bars
has some precision associated with it
and of course we can imagine that
precision getting better and better but
when it gets down to quantum gravity
scales
maybe the whole idea of doing that
measurement just breaks down and isn't
good anymore so you're right what you're
putting your finger on is the idea that
if the model of an electron as a
classically starting as a point particle
on a continuum and then quantizing that
that would give you an infinite
dimensional hilbert space and the number
of worlds could be infinite but nature
might not be like that because nature
has gravity in it so we just don't know
is the correct answer right now
dmi says if regions across which a
function can be analytically continued
all contain the same information about
the function
and if quantum fields have analytic
properties and if unitary information is
contained in quantum fields then how can
a black hole in one region cause the
information in different regions outside
the event horizon to be paradoxically
destroyed
uh i don't think the quantum fields have
analytic properties there's no reason
for them to i mean it may be that in
some particular state
quantum fields have analytic properties
but in an arbitrary state they don't so
for those of you who don't know
in functional analysis in differential
equations and subset differential
equations that thinks about the
properties of functions
there is a very very very special kind
of function called an analytic function
and analytic functions have the
properties that in some small region you
know between x equals 10 and 11
i give you exactly what the function
does between x equals 10 and x equals
11. and the analyticity analyticity is a
property of functions that they may or
may not have
such that if they have it
then the data of what the function is
doing between x equals 10 and x equals
11
is sufficient to tell you what x is
doing at what the function is doing at x
equals 12 or 13 or 14 or minus 12 or a
billion or anything else everywhere else
okay
so analytic functions are very very very
very special functions most functions if
i just tell you what the function does
between 10 and 11 it doesn't tell you
anything about what the function does
anywhere else
so often in physics in special
circumstances like the vacuum of a
quantum field theory it's nice to
imagine that our functions are analytic
it tells us something about what they're
doing all over the place
but the whole point of the black hole
information problem is that we're not in
the vacuum we have a black hole we've
dumped some information into it and once
that happens it's it's there's no reason
to think that the behavior of a function
in one region of space tells you what
the function is doing elsewhere
so
i don't think that there's any relevance
to the black hole information puzzle
maxwell's demon asks a priority question
is there a path into physics higher
education for someone who self-studies
despite getting an undergrad degree in a
different subject to clarify this
question is more about the actual path
to higher ed assuming i'm able to attain
proficiency but if you have tips on
learning that would be great also right
so i should have grouped this with the
previous question but that was mostly
about learning this is about you know
the path to higher ed
so you know the let's remember the
typical path for an academic physicist
you get an undergraduate degree you get
a graduate degree you get a
post-doctoral research position and then
you get a faculty job and ultimately you
get tenure and then you
get elected to the national academy and
win the nobel prize who knows what will
happen after those but those are the
typical career steps so in principle you
can get in at any level right in
principle
um
it becomes harder and harder to get in
the higher the levels are because
there's just very few resources there
are few faculty jobs fewer faculty jobs
in our undergraduate
student positions right um so
if you get an undergraduate degree in a
different study in a different field
than physics but then study physics it's
possible to get into grad school um you
just need to convince some department
that they should admit you and that
actually often happens believe it or not
um
departments are kind of morbidly curious
about people with different backgrounds
and they might be skeptical at first but
if you can convince them that you would
do well in grad school then they would
often be happy to take a chance remember
you can apply to 50 grad schools and you
only need one to take you
um
how do you demonstrate that proficiency
the simplest way is to really
get a killer score on the physics gres
right that's that's one simple way but
maybe there are other ways letters of
recommendation or something like that
that you could do it
if you
didn't if you thought that you were
already advanced enough to be at the
equivalent of already having a phd
and instead you were not applying to
grad schools but wanted to apply for
jobs for postdoc jobs or for faculty
jobs
very often into postdoc job ads there is
a requirement that you have a phd and
and they're not trying to be gatekeepers
keeping out you know
rogue physicists who've taught
themselves they just don't want people
who are you know undergrads to skip the
phd step right they want people to get
that training
but i can imagine you could convince
someone to hire you as a postdoc if you
didn't have a phd and the way to do it
is write really good physics papers get
them published in journals you know if
you write a really good physics paper
submit them to the physical review they
will if it's a sensible paper they will
get a refereed and publish it and if you
have a track record of publishing good
papers then people will be interested in
hiring you i mean in math this actually
happens right in math there are stories
of people who are completely untrained
but are just geniuses and do great
things and then everyone wants to hire
them
it's easier said than done it's very
very hard to do because
the training that you get in school is
not just in the subject matter but all
that informal
folk wisdom that you soak up from being
in the environment and having an advisor
and talking to students and doing
collaborative research and things like
that so it's hard but it's not
impossible
vincent ohm says is there a non-physical
aspect to information suppose we have
two book pages one contains the theory
of everything in a language we do not
understand and the other contains the
recipe for an apple pie in english
does the latter have a higher
information content just because we can
read and understand it
well you know guess what it's going to
depend on your definition of the word
information
and that definition i know you should
say yes but i can look it up in a
dictionary or so forth but we use words
like information differently in
different contexts
so
one definition of information
is a correlation
between uh one physical configuration
and another one right so if i have a
photograph
okay that photograph contains
information because there is a strong
correlation between the image in that
photograph and the image of the thing i
took a picture of right
and there's no interpretive step
involved in something like that it's
just a true fact and that's i can
absolutely say that's information even
if there was no one looking at the
picture whoever would look at the
picture the information is still there
so therefore in that sense if i had an
untranslatable manuscript
if it really does say something correct
about the real world it contains
information absolutely now that
information might be inaccessible to us
so there might be another
notion of information which is something
like the accessible information right
the usable information
and that might be much much less
so you know if you if you take a book
and burn it as we previously talked
about the podcast
at the level of fundamental physics
information is conserved
the positions of all the atoms the
molecules in the book which contained
information is in principle still there
after you burned it but in practice
you're not getting it back so in
practice you burned that information you
destroyed it so in that sense that's the
sense in which having a a text in a
language that you can't translate you
might as well not have any information
that's accessible at all
okay i'm going to group two questions
together
anonymous says
alice is a character in a fantasy world
and she can do magic she's helping bob a
farmer by using her magic to teleport
his cows across a river
alice knows two kinds of teleport spell
the first kind of spell works like a
star trek transporter she destroys the
cow and creates an exact copy of the
other side of the river the second type
of spell targets the fabric of
space-time and temporarily connects the
cow's location by a wormhole i suppose
with the new location on the other side
of the root of the river
though alice can perform impossible
feats
her magic still follows rules and comes
with limitations and she wants to be as
efficient as possible
if the complexity and difficulty of her
spell is proportional to the complexity
and difficulty of the change he's trying
to make in reality
which spell is easier and uses less
energy you can assume spherical cows
thank you for letting me assume
spherical cows that's very helpful uh
and then matt hickman says if i take a
star trek transporter from location a to
b did i die at location a and a new
being get created by b at b with my
memories and does your answer vary
depending on transporter implementation
that's why i group these two together so
first mats actually i should probably
group mats together
with the previous question
about the self in many worlds now that i
think about it but
i don't think you died i mean the the
question is so let's back up if you take
a teleporter machine transporter machine
so you disappear at one location and
you're reassembled at another one okay
um
one attitude would be
there is some essence
to yourself
that is physically attached to your body
and that essence ceases to be attached
to your body when you transport and
therefore you die
and the thing that is assembled at the
other location is something that is
looks like you talks like you has all
your memories but it doesn't have that
essence so it's not you
as you might guess this is not my view
i don't think there are any such
essences i think that the world is the
stuff in it and what the stuff is doing
so
to me
the fact that i disappeared here and
appeared somewhere else because of the
transporter machine
it doesn't affect any of the reasons why
i would conventionally think of my
future self as part of the same person
as my past self right
technically they're different cells but
i don't think that i'm dying at
literally every moment and then a new
person is coming into existence i attach
some continuity to them and all the
reasons why i might attach that
continuity to them work just as well in
the transporter
uh case if you have a duplicator machine
it's trickier but i think in the
transporter machine i don't think of
yourself as dying
so to anonymous question
it's an interesting question of course
there's no right answer to this because
it's a fantasy question you've already
violated the rules of physics to have
this transporter machine and wormhole at
least the rules of physics as we
understand them and magic et cetera et
cetera so
but you know okay
let's let's play the game by the
postulates that they were being given
here and think about it in his own terms
so i would say
my my
guess my inclination my first
thought
is that the wormhole answer versus the
transporter answer the wormhole answer
is easier
the wormhole procedure is more efficient
than the transporter
machine so and here's why because
in some sense it is using
the existing laws of physics to help it
along
i mean forget about the transporter
forget about the other other side of the
river right in some sense here i am now
and here i am a second later right my
body all of its atoms etc
exist and are related to each other the
configuration all those atoms and all
the organs in my body at one moment at
time is related but not the same as the
configuration of all that stuff one
second later especially if i'm moving
and talking and things like that okay
but it didn't take any effort
for me to be in almost the same
configuration one second later it just
happened because the laws of physics did
it
and i think that if you go to the effort
of building a wormhole or a bridge
through space-time then the sort of
nuanced effort of moving each individual
atom and molecule in the body of the cow
is done by the laws of physics it goes
along for the ride whereas
if you need a transporter machine well
you know you haven't told me the
technology behind your transporter
machine but somehow i have the feeling
that
you're sending the cow molecule by
molecule
you're not letting the laws of physics
move the uh
positions and velocities of all the
parts of the cow you have to do it by
hand in some sense so that seems a lot
less efficient to me but to be honest i
am much less clear on what the
technology the transporter machine would
be than i am on the technology of the
wormhole
okay
bill hughes asks a priority question
in something deeply hidden you've said
that many worlds doesn't violate
conservation of energy because each of
the child branches is thinner because
their amplitude is less i've also heard
you say that the low probability
branches count for less
what real world effect does being in a
branch with less amplitude have what
real thing is amplitude measuring it's
not probability because all the branches
do exist
nor the likelihood of being on a branch
because you are on all of them so the
answer is it's the likelihood of being
on a branch that's the real world effect
of the amplitude and i know you just
said it can't be that because you are on
all of them but you're not on all of
them different people are on all of them
that's the point i mean if you don't
accept that that's fine but then you're
just not going to accept many worlds at
all and you know you should develop some
metaphysical objections to it but what
the many worlds person says is that once
the branching happens
and you have different worlds the
different people on those different
worlds are different people they're not
you on all of them
so there is a question after the
branching happens uh if i exist after
the branching and i know that i'm on one
branch but not the others what which one
am i on
and i assign a probability and that
probability is given by the amplitude
squared that's the relevance of the
amplitude
russell wolfe says what is your opinion
on the use of the word energy in a
psychological context like when we talk
about extroverts gaining energy from
social interactions while introverts are
drained of energy and need to recharge
is there a meaningful physical
definition of energy that matches this
colloquial cloak wheel
colloquial use of the word
um
i'm completely fine with that use of
energy look you know i take yoga classes
or i haven't in a long time but i am all
in favor of taking yoga classes where
the instructors often use all sorts of
crazy words to describe what is going on
i don't care who cares it's a metaphor
right it's a poetic way of talking about
things so the question is is this use of
the word the question in my mind would
be
is the metaphorical
purpose being served by using the word
energy in this context and i think the
answer is absolutely yes i mean we get
it when someone says
they're high energy they're low energy
they gain energy they lose energy
everyone knows what that means and it
doesn't correspond to anything
any physical stuff going into their
bodies or anything like that it has to
do instead with
intricate questions about their
physiological state that are
generally going to be very very complex
okay
uh but i have no objections to that
whatsoever go as long as it's clear
i'm all in favor of it
julie mars says can you recommend a
popular science book that explores the
phenomena associated with phase
transitions across many different
disciplines
i've already read complexity by michael
waldrop but wasn't thrilled with it um
no
i can't really uh recommend that i mean
there is there's the book by malcolm
gladwell the tipping point right where
he tries to use notions that are kind of
phased transition e
to describe some social dynamics and you
know there's some things that are true
that are said in that book but it's not
going to give you insight into the
physics phenomena
nor how the physics phenomena can be
used in broader context
i say this with regret wistfully because
jennifer will act my wife for a while
was planning to write such a book
but alas in the real world if you want
to put a year or so of your life
into the effort of writing a book
someone better buy it
and the booksellers of the world were
not convinced that anyone would buy a
book on phase transitions so i don't
know i mean there could be one out there
that i don't know about uh happy to take
suggestions in the comments
igor kopilov says
you've mentioned that you're writing a
quantum mechanics textbook how do you
balance doing something new with
covering all the standard things that
every qm textbook has to cover do you
reach out to colleagues who teach qm
courses to get their input or are you
just following your own vision
uh you know mostly following my own
vision but i'm certainly looking at
other people's books i'm not talking to
a lot of people i guess i've talked to a
few people who have taught quantum
mechanics but there's a standard
curriculum you know i'm not going to be
surprised by talking to people who have
taught it you know they they um use the
same textbooks et cetera et cetera and
mostly i do want to cover the standard
stuff you know i'm not trying to
revolutionize the teaching of quantum
mechanics but i do want to
nudge it in a productive direction so i
think that
there are ways in which i think they're
pretty clear ways in which the current
way that we teach quantum mechanics
falls short and i don't mean they're not
teaching many worlds i don't even mean
they're not teaching the foundations of
quantum mechanics i do think they should
say true things about the foundations of
quantum mechanics they should be correct
when talking about
the measurement problem or bells
inequality or things like that and
they're often not
okay so i think i can try to get that
better but more importantly
very often uh quantum textbooks are just
excuses to solve the schrodinger
equation over and over and over again
um most often for single particle
systems
and the notion that particles can be
entangled
uh
is mentioned and then slid by right so
that's terrible that that to me is just
doing a disservice to what makes quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics so i think
that
without getting philosophical or
anything like that about it
i definitely want to do a lot more than
the typical quantum mechanics books does
uh to explain both the phenomenon of
entanglement and the uh technical
apparatus that goes along with thinking
about it decoherence and density
matrices and things like that
and this is not just because i think
it's interesting and true although
there's that it's also relevant to how
we use quantum mechanics in the modern
world whether we are grown-up uh
professors
that are now doing research in quantum
mechanics or whether you go into uh
industry to build a quantum computer
quantum computers rely on entanglement
and it turns out that it's not that hard
and enormous fun to teach people the
basics of quantum information and
quantum computing that's a hundred
percent
appropriate for an intro quantum course
so ideally if it all works out there
will be stuff like that in my quantum
textbook but it'll be optional
entanglement will be there non-optional
um but then you can choose to still you
know spend a lot of time doing klipsch
gordon coefficients and additions of
spins and uh time-dependent perturbation
theory if that's what gets your juices
flowing or you can do quantum
information in quantum computing if
that's what gets your juices flowing
that's the goal we'll see if it all pans
out gregory kuznick says in last month's
ama you argued that since events at the
scale of human affairs are effectively
classical and deterministic we should
expect histories that diverge radically
from our own like the nazis won world
war ii to have very low probability
i don't see how this follows it seems to
me there's ample scope for quantum
uncertainties in things like genetic
recombination and the rectum random
activation of oncogenes to have profound
effects on who gets born and who dies
early this would lead me to expect a
diverse array of very different
histories all with roughly equal measure
so i think that's a fair point here but
the
you know there is a
footnote that is crucial which is
when you're thinking about the wave
function branching
so as you think about branchings of the
wave function that go earlier and
earlier in time
then you can have a tiny fluctuation a
tiny difference at very early times lead
to an enormous difference in the present
era
just for the most dramatic example if
you believe in inflationary cosmology
then literally the fluctuations that led
to galaxies forming are quantum
measurement outcomes that would be very
different in different branches of the
wave function so the earth in our galaxy
the milky way galaxy wouldn't exist in a
large number of other branches of the
wave function that's certainly very
different okay
what i was thinking what i was
implicitly assuming which i shouldn't
have implicitly done i could have done
it and said it out loud uh was that
there were
we were talking about branchings that
were relatively recent so i'm not even
talking about who is born and who dies i
was talking about the uh actions taken
by the leadership of the countries
during the 1930s and 1940s
i think there the room for large
variations is much smaller it can happen
but i think the probability is much
lower
but sure if you are including branches
that branched off a long long time ago
if even if you go back you know
thousands or millions of years so the
genetic histories could be very
different then yes you could get
histories now that look quite different
johann livgren says i enjoyed your
recent paper the quantum field theory on
which the everyday world supervenes and
i find myself largely in agreement
but i'm worried that the issue of
naturalness is being swept under the rug
from effective field theory principles
we expect the standard model higgs mass
and cosmological constant to be much
larger than what we have measured when
we are considering the completeness of
the core theory should it not give us
pause that the standard wilsonian
effective field theory principles do not
seem to lead us right here
sure so what's going on here is i made
an argument in this paper
that on the basis of what we think we
understand about effective field
theories
we have very good reason to believe that
any variations of the core theory the
standard model of particle physics plus
general relativity
would be irrelevant to everyday life
things in particular things that go on
in a brain or a biological organism and
uh crossing symmetry and other features
of quantum field theory are important
for that argument but so are the idea
that the dynamics of the fields we
already know about
is pretty well understood so
there is a weaker argument that i made
that still works you know even if you
don't believe the rules of not the rules
but the expectations of effective field
theory those expectations tell us that
there could be new interactions
um well we call irrelevant or higher
dimensional operators in the quantum
field theory
but the sizes of those interactions are
very very small that is a prediction of
effective field three or so i keep
saying prediction an expectation it's
not a strong prediction it's just we
expect in a reasonable non non-finely
tuned theory that these extra
interactions are very small so two
things to say about that one is
we could be wrong
and what johann is bringing up is
there's two famous examples where we are
wrong the higgs mass and the
cosmological constant
now they're both special those two
quantities are both special in effective
field theory as
um
relevant operators that they're only two
relevant operators that we can write
down and so it turns out that in the
core theory there are two relevant
operators and our field theory our
effective field of expectations for them
are wrong in both cases
um but that doesn't mean that we're
wrong about marginal operators or
irrelevant operators so there's no
immediate worry but it does remind you
these are just expectations and you can
be wrong about them okay so to that
extent this is a perfectly good issue
that johan raises however
it doesn't really help you
because even if you
were very skeptical about that
particular expectation of effective
field theory what could you get by
violating the expectation of effective
field theory well we've already measured
the
coefficients of the parts of the
standard model we know right the masses
and the kinetic energies of the ordinary
particles and fields the only room
uh for changing the dynamics of the
known fields is in their higher order
interactions right how an electron
interacts with two photons at once or
something like that and the point is
that even if that interaction was much
larger than we expected
who cares
it's not going to affect everyday life
in any interesting way right in order to
have this kind of effect we either need
truly new fields that are pushing around
the fields of the um standard model in
some uh
non-obvious way or we need something
dramatically uh
in violation of effective field theory
principles like a violation of locality
that's really what people want the
people who want to change the laws of
physics
in order to have an impact on
consciousness they don't care about
higher order operators what they care
about is that electrons in the context
of a human brain
behave differently than the same
electron would behave in the context of
a rock
and that's not just a matter of
the expectations of higher order
non-normalizable operators being off
that's just a total violation of
everything we know and love about field
theory so i'm not worried about that
loophole actually being exploited in
nature
herbert berkovitz says is there a
philosophy to mathematics or is it just
one of those things that is what it is
uh so yeah there's absolutely a
philosophy to mathematics uh you might
remember that i did a podcast where we
talk about it uh with justin clark doan
we talked about the philosophy of
mathematics and morality um and their
relationship to each other but a lot of
it was just philosophy of mathematics
you very quickly get into questions
about mathematics like
can things be true even if you haven't
proven them what does it mean to be
consistent what kinds of trans finite
numbers are there you know
are mathematical objects real in some
platonic sense or are they just
conventional or just names there's a
whole bunch of good questions the
philosophy of math so yeah google it
it's out there
brendan says
you've mentioned before that you've done
casual research on information theory
and i was curious as to what
about that field interests you i tried
doing some research on the topic and
noticed that entropy plays a big role in
information theory but i don't quite
understand why that is any insight into
this would be great
um yeah i you know i've written a couple
papers that i wouldn't call them papers
on information theory but they're papers
where information theory played a
crucial role
most obviously in my papers on emerging
space time with charles tsao and spiros
mikalakis we used mutual information
between quantum mutual information
between degrees of freedom to define an
immersion metric on space-time so that's
a pretty kind of trivial
once you know what mutual information is
that's not it does not really using the
heavy
uh machinery of information theory um
more interesting in that context was a
paper i wrote with stephen lychenauer
and jason [ __ ] and tony bartlotta on
the bayesian second law of
thermodynamics
i still think that this paper is more
important than people give it credit for
because it answers it's the kind of
thing i like to do it answers this
question of principle
that many people weren't worried about
but i think they should have been
worried about namely
how do you deal with the fact that on
the one hand you say entropy increases
on the second hand you say that entropy
is a measure of our ignorance and on the
third hand you learn things as you look
at the world right as you actually uh
cosmos lizzie pointed this out and wrote
a whole paper about it how
in some weird sense a good bayesian sees
a reversed arrow of time right because
you just learn more and more about the
world and therefore the entropy of the
world goes down
now of course that's using a very
specific
uh epistemic notion of entropy which is
different than the thermodynamic notion
that we usually mean in cosmology so
it's not actually a conflict with
anything that we know but it's an
interesting question how do you
reconcile those
so the bayesian second law which is
something that we derived
answered the question
if you take the ordinary second law of
thermodynamics and include in it
the fact that you can measure systems
and therefore learn about them
is there some notion of something going
up some some measure some quantity like
entropy that increases even though
you're doing measurements and we found
yes and we derived a rule and it has to
do with the relative entropy of
different distributions and all that is
very very information theoretic
um so that was a lot of fun
we haven't we didn't really give a
killer app for that so the reason why it
hasn't gotten a lot of attention is
what are you gonna do with it right i
mean to get other people interested in
it you need to be able to say okay you
can use this new equation this new
theorem that you derived
to do some experiment or you know build
something or something like that and
that we didn't quite do we have
had and have ambitions to do it but
until we do that i can't really blame
the rest of the world for not getting
too excited
frank layman says is there a
long-standing problem in science
mathematics or philosophy that your
colleagues treat as a huge very
difficult deal but that you don't think
is particularly serious or important and
conversely is there a problem you think
of
is the utmost importance where the
consensus is that it's solved or
unimportant or maybe even not recognized
as a problem
so yeah you know i mean the latter is
much more uh true like generally
speaking
i'm trying to think but i think that
most problems that the scientific
establishment thinks are really really
interesting
um
maybe i don't think that they're really
really interesting but i generally get
it i generally think that you know there
is interest in doing that okay i i
you know after reading your question i
tried to think of a really killer
example of something everyone else cared
about and i don't but i i couldn't think
of one um but there are certainly things
that no one else cares about or very few
people care about that i do
um you know the big question obvious
answer is just the foundations of
quantum mechanics
generally and for that matter the
foundations of statistical mechanics and
probability and cosmology and all these
other things you know um i know it's
been a long time you know these days
since my most recent book is on quantum
mechanics i'm known as the many worlds
guy but 10 years ago i was known as the
arrow of time guy because my first book
from eternity to here was all about
cosmology and the arrow of time my
interest in that has not gone away and i
still think
that the fact that the early universe
had a low entropy is really really
really important to understand and why
cosmology buddies don't always go along
with that so what can i tell you i've
lots of questions lots of lots of issues
along those lines
keith says
i was recently be listening to the james
ladyman episode on structural realism
and i found myself wondering about your
current thoughts on the topic that you
might share more about
i.e is either epistemic or optic
structural realism something you find
congruous with your positions on the
ontological status of things like the
wave function and hilbert space
so for those of you who don't remember
the episode with james ladyman uh james
is one of the leading proponents of this
view called structural realism
and it goes in these epistemic and antic
varieties so what does that mean
it means
that
the way i think about it and you know
i've talked with james and i've read
things that he's written and things that
other people have written and you know
we had the podcast episode but it's
still a little subtle and so i don't
want to claim that my version of it is
the consensus version of it not that i'm
trying to be contrarian but that my
understanding might not quite be there
yet so let me say the way i understand
it
you know thomas kuhn famously
emphasized the fact that when we have a
scientific revolution
it's not just that we improve the old
theory we very often throw away the old
theory that we throw away the ontology
of the old theory and replace it with
something completely different quantum
mechanics is an obvious example to that
but also something like relativity right
in relativity pre-relativity we had
space and time as two separate things
and now we have space time it's like a
completely different thing especially in
general relativity where gravity is not
a force propagating on top of space-time
but a feature of space-time a feature of
the curvature of space-time so in kuhn's
view that that revolutionary science is
really throwing away the old paradigm
and replacing it with something new
what the structural realists are trying
to emphasize is that you're not throwing
away everything
maybe you are throwing away the ontology
maybe you are throwing away your idea of
what is the fundamental stuff of the
universe right in classical mechanics
your fundamental stuff is some particles
or some
fields and they move through space-time
and obey equations in quantum mechanics
your fundamental stuff is a wave
function which is an entirely different
kind of thing
but there is some similarity
if quantum mechanics is going to be
successful at the end of the day it
better predict that the earth goes
around the sun
if general relativity is going to be
successful it better had better predict
the same thing the phenomenon of the
earth going around the sun
is independent of your idea of the
underlying ontology whether it's
four-dimensional space-time or newtonian
space-time classical mechanics quantum
mechanics or whatever
so the structural realists say that the
thing that is real
is are the things that are preserved
through these transitions from one
theory to another
and they talk about in terms of the
structure of what relates to what and
you could say you know it's a way of
mapping your fundamental theoretical
formalism to your experience to your
observations to your informal
uh view of the world when we say the
earth goes around the sun what we mean
is there's some observations of where
the sun is in the sky and where the
other planets are and they are most
easily explained by thinking of the
earth that's going around the sun and
rotating around its axis
so it's those relationships between
different pieces of the world and the
relationships between our observations
and the formalism that are preserved and
improved over time not thrown away
entirely and replaced with something
else
so there are reasons why there are
there's an epistemic version of this and
an optic version of this
the
epistemic version is the one i think i
understand and agree with which is that
this whole picture
where we throw away ontologies and
replace them with better ones but keep
some structures along the way
is a statement about our knowledge it's
the same about what we human beings are
doing okay there's something true about
the world and we're learning more and
more about it and what we're learning
more and more about is not just uh
putting more ingredients into our
ontology
but it may be a completely new ontology
that explains the structure a little bit
better okay that would be epistemic
structural realism
ontic structural realism is i think if i
understand it again not promising you
anything there is a bit more dramatic
trying to be the claim that
these structures are what really exist
that's what ontic means really existing
right it's not just that we know these
structures we learn about them
but regardless of our knowledge it's the
structures that exist
i don't know what to make of that i
don't know what what that would mean
like how does a
relationship between things exist if the
things don't exist that's my worry about
antic structural realism but epistemic
structural realism i think that james
and other people have convinced me is a
good way to go but you know
i haven't reached conclusions about
these things once again i keep saying
this over and over again during this
podcast that's okay
living at the boundaries of our
knowledge is a fun place to hang out
kathy seeger says a book that is thrown
into the fire a physicist would say that
information is conserved because in
principle it can be reconstructed
to reconstruct it would be needed to
hypothetically keep track of the
microscopic degrees of freedom of the
system and then reverse everything back
in time to deduce the initial state of
the book from the final state of the
smoke and ashes
and also the radiation don't forget the
radiation
but how could that work out when
macroscopic systems or in fact the
universe as a whole is asymmetric under
time reversal and during that
hypothetical reconstruction process
going from higher back to lower entropy
aren't there more possibilities for the
microstates on the higher entropy side
of things to evolve back to
uh so i think there's two separate
things going on here
one is the macro micro distinction so
you know whenever people talk about
these thought experiments they don't
mean you're ever going to do it or even
you should ever think about trying to
imagine doing it
in fact here's why you couldn't do it
because you say let's capture all the
information contained in the smoke and
ashes and the radiation
well you can't because in quantum
mechanics when you measure the position
of a photon for example you change it
right you collapse its wave function so
you can
not actually know
by doing measurements what the state of
the photon was before you measured it
which is what you would need to have in
order to reconstruct the book
so we're not ever talking about actually
anything something that could be done by
people even super duper people it's just
impossible to do it what we mean when we
say the information is still there is
that in the
universe
as a whole
the universe knows
the complete state of the universe even
though it's inaccessible to us because
of the uncertainty principle etc the
complete state of the universe contains
the right information
um to reconstruct the book okay so it's
not you know macroscopically it's just
inaccessible to us and the fact that
macroscopic physics is irreversible is a
reflection of the fact that that
information is inaccessible to us but
that's completely compatible with the
microscopic physics preserving the
information over time
now the
other thing that you mentioned
is i think a little bit more interesting
and provocative you say that are there
more possibilities for the microstates
on the higher entropy side of things to
evolve back to
so
yeah you know when you're in a high
entropy state like after you've burned
the book
in the macro state that you are in
there's the ash a certain amount of
radiation blah blah blah in that macro
state there are more microstates than
there were in the initial book before
you burned it okay entropy went up
that's what you mean
so what that means is that
for a typical micro state in that macro
state
so if all you knew was there was some
ash some dust some radiation you knew
its macroscopic properties but you
didn't know its microstate
and someone gave you a specific example
of that microstate and said evolved it
backward
it would not evolve back into the book
the overwhelming majority of such
microstates would not even evolve into
lower entropy states in the past they
would evolve into higher entropy states
also in the past right
because the information that the book
used to exist
and used to be in a lower entropy state
is still implicit in the micro state of
the ashes in smoke and radiation it's
just inaccessible to us macroscopically
so we know that it used to be there
because we knew there used to be a book
but just the macroscopically accessible
information is not enough
for us to know
that it even could be reversed into a
lower entropy state much less how to do
it
p walder says i often hear scientists
say that life on earth only ever
originated once does this literally mean
that there was only ever one in one
that there was only ever one instance of
some chance chemical event which
subsequently resulted in the evolution
of all known bacteria plants etc
if so doesn't this point to an
incredibly rare event and makes the
likelihood of finding life elsewhere in
the universe very very unlikely
so um
i don't think you often hear scientists
say that
at least uh not when they're speaking
carefully what scientists like to say
or should be saying is that
all life on earth came from a common
ancestor
so there is luca the last universal
common ancestor
we don't think
that different species of life on earth
now
have family trees that are completely
disjoint we think that every living
organism on earth can be traced back to
luca in some sense
that's not the same as saying that life
on earth only ever originated once it
means that
if there were multiple origins
either
most of them didn't survive at all
or
some of them combined to make our last
common ancestor so having one
universal common ancestor doesn't mean
it was the first ancestor
so it's possible that you know life
originated 20 times and 12 of those died
out and eight of them sort of got
together somehow to make luca right i
don't know but this is a hypothetically
hypothetically conceivable uh set of
events so maybe sometimes scientists say
the life on earth only have originated
once but we don't know that and they
shouldn't say that
um now having said all that
it's also possible you know life we
think originated who knows what 3.5
billion years ago or something like that
maybe life is rare in its origin but not
super rare so you know maybe there's a
chance of it coming into existence one
every 500 million years
so over the course of the existence of
life it's come into existence several
times
but
after the first time it was already
crowded there's already life here and
the life that came into existence either
was absorbed or eliminated by the
existing life that's also possible
so i do think that uh
you know we have enough evidence to say
that life doesn't appear immediately and
easily like we haven't made it in our
test tubes right there's a little bit of
effort involved um but i don't think we
have enough information to say that it's
very very very unlikely either the
universe is a big place
there's a number the chance that life
comes into existence that we multiply by
another number the number of possible
places life could come into existence
one of those numbers is small the other
is big and we just don't really know
what you get when you multiply them by
each other
okay dominic adam jones says
as a scientifically expert morally
serious person
how do you square the climate crisis
with your willingness to fly fairly
regularly
so i think the short answer is um
dick cheney was right you know i'm
giving dick too much credit usually i
have no credit at all though so this
should count for something dick cheney
back when he was running uh on the uh
presidential ticket with as vice
presidential candidate with george w
bush was asked about energy conservation
in particular
individual efforts to conserve energy
right you know use better light bulbs
etc and he said look that's a matter of
personal virtue he didn't consider it to
be a matter of public policy and i agree
with that you know um i disagree with
him about the public policy itself
should be
but this whole idea that individuals are
going to make choices about light bulbs
and and traveling and what car to drive
seems to me to be not only irrelevant to
climate change but actively unhelpful
because it's not going to help you know
as we talked about with herbagentus the
fact that there's no point in voting
if all you wanted to do was be a
consequentialist the reason why we vote
is to sort of demonstrate some loyalty
or because we think it's a rule that
everyone should obey and in some kantian
sense etc
but
me not flying would have i mean strictly
zero effect on the climate right because
the same planes would fly like my choice
not to fly would not affect the flight
of the plains
even if a hundred people choose not to
fly it's just not going to have a big
effect the way to solve the climate
crisis is through collective action
of course it is and collective action
comes through governments and
international cooperation and things
like that i think if you're serious
about the climate crisis what you worry
about or is public policy not whether an
individual person is driving a
gas car or an electric car or something
like that you need to think much much
much bigger
what i want in other words is a system
that makes it easy
to treat the planet well rather than
relying on individual good deeds which
will never ever ever do the job we need
to incentivize
systems that don't cause harm to the
planet make fossil fuels really really
expensive incentivize alternatives
give people ways to live their lives so
that the choices that make them happiest
are the ones that are good for the
planet that's the kind of system we
should set up not just hectoring people
into behaving well it doesn't help
and last question for this ama fabian
rosalind says i saw you get referenced
by rationally rationality rules in his
video on why is there something rather
than nothing and whilst i think you
agree with him there it got me thinking
has there been any case where you felt
misrepresented by someone in a
documentary video article or something
like that and how do you cope with that
oh my goodness yes is the
answer here um i mean maybe this is just
obvious but certainly i've learned
empirically through experience that once
you
do some
communication in the public sphere once
other people read what you write or
listen to what you say and then talk
about it you will constantly
be misrepresented it happens all the
time people are constantly saying
attributing to me
not only
misrepresentations of what i said but
literally the opposite of things that i
would say all the time
people say that i think that
there's no more reason to take evidence
and observation into consideration when
we do science people think people have
said that i think it's possible to
mathematically disprove the existence of
god uh people say lots of crazy things
you know what are you gonna do um
most of the time
the people's audiences are relatively
small and life is short and i don't
bother to be honest like you can't run
around sometimes i get emails
from someone saying oh you know someone
wrote an article or someone um published
a video that that misrepresents
something you've said
yeah life is short i try to be clear in
what i say you know um
i mean i knew when i started talking
about the fact that the laws of physics
underlying everyday life are completely
known
everyone was going to misrepresent that
and indeed they do all the time
and i don't mean the person i just uh
responded to in the ama but some people
get it really really wrong and you know
they they just willfully misunderstand
in ways that i knew they would
misunderstand and i said in the article
don't please don't misunderstand it in
the following way
and they do it anyway
because you know
i mean i'm making fun of people of
course but look we're all finite right
we all have limited capacity uh both to
read things and to understand them and
to talk about them and so on and so on
and that i'm included in that and when i
talk about what other people
say and have said
i'm sure that i cut corners and i and i
misrepresent them not
intentionally but you know
i have ways of thinking and if i'm
trying to understand someone else's way
of thinking it's generally going to fit
into pre-existing categories in my brain
and sometimes that fit does violence to
the original idea and so it's very
natural that people misunderstand that's
not an excuse
you shouldn't get away with it just for
that reason but i get why it happens and
so
you know the the solution is just that
all of us should make good faith efforts
to
um
be honest and accurate when we are
when we were saying things uh that other
that were when we were attributing views
to other people right i tried to be
clear myself i try to anticipate ways in
which i can be misunderstood
and
what else can i do you know i'm not
going to chase around everyone who
misrepresents me if it becomes someone
famous
then maybe i will you know explain on
social media or whatever that that was a
misunderstanding but you know if it's
just everyday things certain punches you
have to roll with like someone said on
twitter recently um
you have to pick your battles and then
the joke was wait no that's a lot of
battles you're picking too many battles
pick fewer battles put some battles down
i i'm very much in a believer in that
particular philosophy you have to pick
your battles there's an infinite number
of battles
life and and energy are finite let's
pick the best ones that we can pick and
with that as usual thank you very much
for listening this far thanks very much
for supporting mindscape i hope you're
having as much fun listening to it and
thinking about it as i am making it have
a good month
[Music]
you